I just realized I forgot to set up some stuff no for my end I'm at my no no no I mean like I need to have you guys on my screen I really forgot about that I was like, there is something I forgot about!
How do you do the Discord overlay?
It's like, I use Foogey.
Oh crap, I'm just too lazy now.
Yeah, no, if I wasn't a streamer, I'd be lazy too!
And I was like, wait a minute, I knew something was missing on my screen.
Something very important.
Hey, where the fuck is this guy?
Alright, here you go.
Hey, where are you?
You're not on my screen.
Where is this?
Sorry, very professional chat, I know.
This is...
We're starting off very strong here.
Alright, there's you.
You're gonna be far away from me, Tempo.
So, hello everybody.
I hope Tempo is not too loud.
Hello.
I hope he is not too loud, guys.
Am I not too loud?
I don't know, actually.
Your mic is like...
You're like, in a very empty...
In a very empty room.
That's what...
Your room has definitely had no soundproofing done.
Wait, wait, wait.
My mic has four things.
It has the Olympic circle thingy.
What the fuck does that mean?
It has just a circle.
It has something that looks like a fortune cookie.
Oh, wait, do you have a Blue Yeti?
Yeah.
Okay, yeah, I was gonna say, that sounds like a Blue Yeti shit right there.
So, what do I do?
Fortune cookie?
I don't know.
It could be a circle or the Olympic thing.
Sound people.
What does... What should he do?
I... Okay, you...
Yeah, sound people help me out here.
I'm not like a sound person.
What the fuck do you... Why would I know this?
It seems like...
You're a streamer.
I thought... I thought you would know.
Yeah, I'm a streamer that outsources to other people on things that I don't know.
Like, sound being one of them.
I'm just here to choose things that look pretty.
That's really all I do.
Like...
Do you think I know anything about sound?
Oh, you want fortune cookie.
Everyone says fortune cookie.
I am on a fortune cookie.
Why the fuck do you sound like you're in an... Do you have any, like... Like...
I have stuff in my room.
Do you have, like, any... It just feels like your room is, like, super empty.
That's what it sounds like.
I think because my door is open.
Does that make a difference?
Bro, I don't know.
Does it actually?
Yeah, he sounds like you're... It sounds like you're in the bathroom.
Someone's, like, pad your wall.
That's true.
I was gonna say that too.
I was gonna say, like, push shit around your room.
Door is closed.
Does that... Does that change anything?
I guess it, like, improved a little bit.
It's, like, a little bit better.
But it's still... It's so weird.
It sounds like... Yeah, it sounds like you're literally in a bathroom.
That's really it.
Like, my room has stuff in it.
Yeah, but you need stuff on your walls.
Oh, there's nothing on the walls.
Yeah, that's why.
You need stuff on your walls.
That's why.
Should I just fill it with all those posters that... Yeah!
Your fans sent?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I'll send you a list.
Wait!
Wait, you should!
Just all the... Just all the acoustic Doki posters?
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah!
It'll give you better soundproofing.
You should!
I'll give you a list of artists to buy from.
And then...
Okay, Doki artists.
If you have any Doki prints sent up on Etsy or anything, let me know.
And I'll make Tempo buy them with his own money.
He has the TSM money.
Which isn't a lot, but, like...
Sorry, I should say that.
But if you get paid very well, Tempo...
TSM money.
Which is it?
You get paid very well, Tempo, for what you do.
Oh, no.
Don't worry.
I was spreading misinformation earlier, guys.
Don't... Don't put this on any eSport reporting news that a VTuber just...
Exposed payroll.
Guys, it was just a joke.
I swear.
I... I am so warmed up.
Now, I can't wait to...
Not hit any of these shots in the actual game.
Is... Is, like... Is, like, Wig still in the interview?
That's such a long interview.
I think so.
Where... Where is Wig?
Oh, my God.
I like how, like...
Wig is, like, the name of the tournament.
But, uh...
Greek is Cassie.
Wait, Greek is Cassie?
Isn't he playing?
Yeah!
Yeah, isn't... Wait, isn't he... Is he playing?
Wait...
Yeah, he's playing.
He's playing.
He's on one of the teams.
Why the fuck did I say Greek?
Oh, it says, Geek Lounge!
Oh, I thought that said Greek!
That would be so funny, though.
Oh, oh, wait.
Okay, in interviews.
Okay, got it.
That would've been so funny, though, if, like, Greek was the one casting it.
Oh, he should have cast it.
He should have casted it.
He should have... It would've been so funny!
It would've been really funny.
Also, guys, how is, um...
How was tempo?
Should I raise him up, or should I keep him this volume?
I don't know if Sound Guy is awake right now.
I'm still in the bathroom, so it's okay.
Yeah.
Tempo sounds good.
I'm playing from the toilet.
Yeah, he is.
So, we do pretty badly...
To be fair, there's a lot of things against us right now.
Wait, where are the... Where are the listed teams?
That's not it.
It's in announcements, I think.
Guys, I just want you guys to know...
I'm gonna talk about this again when Wick joins us.
But, like, our team technically consists of two Plat players.
And a Gold player.
Cuz, wait, Tempo, you're Gold, right?
Who's the Gold player?
I'm in Plat.
You're in Plat?
Oh, three Plat.
Wait, no, is Wick in Gold or Plat?
Wick said he was in Plat.
It's three Plat players.
Oh, it's three Plat players.
Okay, it's okay.
I put two Plats and a Gold to increase engagement.
Wick's the Gold, right?
It looks better when I have a Gold in my title.
Cuz people are like, whoa, and a Gold player?
Okay, let me go de-rank myself here.
Yeah, I mean, that would be easy.
Where am I?
Actually, I'm very close to de-ranking.
Okay, it's for the views.
Anyway, so our team technically consists of three Plat players.
And the thing is that...
If you guys watched the drafting stage on Wick's stream...
I was on the list and it listed me as Plat 4.
Because technically...
Technically...
I had Plat 4.
As Doki Bird.
So I was listed as Plat 4.
So no one...
So people were like, who the fuck is this Plat 4 shitter?
Yeah.
So...
I committed the greatest heist of all time.
Convincing staff I was Plat 4.
I did say...
No, I did it right.
I was like, ooh, Masters.
But I play like a Plat player.
So...
That's why...
I literally said...
Okay, the reason why I was in Plat 4...
Was cuz they were like, what's your rank?
And I was like...
Well...
I got Masters...
In the last...
What was it?
Five seasons.
But...
I play like a Plat player.
And then they're like...
Okay.
Give us your like...
Tracker thing.
And apparently the tracker lists your average rank.
Overall.
And my average rank overall on...
As Doki...
Is Plat.
I
got away with it!
Yeah!
I can't believe it!
I can't...
How does she keep getting away with this?
How does she keep doing this?
Oh my God!
It's so fucking crazy!
Somebody stop her!
Change the bat!
Oh, don't worry.
Don't worry guys.
Don't worry.
I'm way ahead of you.
So I improved!
Don't worry guys!
I thought of this too!
I thought of it as well!
I do...
I have one singular Plat badge.
I just need you guys to know that.
All...
Out of all the badges, I actually have one singular PLAT badge.
Okay, here, let me show you guys.
Um...
Where's the badges?
Look...
We're gonna ignore that, but...
Look at that!
My... my one singular PLAT badge!
Right here.
We're gonna ignore the other badges, chat.
We're gonna ignore the other ones.
We're gonna look at the ones that matter right now.
Alright?
The ones that matter.
Welcome back.
Hey, welcome back!
Thanks, dude.
So, how was the interview?
It was good.
They said, uh, hope you win.
I just started laughing.
Oh.
Cause we're totally gonna win, right?
No, for sure, for sure.
Wait, what about now?
What do you mean, what about now?
What do you mean?
Does it still sound like I'm in a bad mood?
Oh.
Yes.
Yeah, it definitely does.
A little bit.
Wait, I just realized.
Oh my god.
They, like, locked out some of the badges because they haven't fixed it yet.
Oh no, really?
I just realized that.
Cause I was like, wait, I am missing badges.
What the fuck?
My PLAT badges, of course.
That's what I'm saying.
Yeah, of course.
You don't have any other badges.
Yeah, yeah.
My PLAT badges.
Cause like, for some reason, on my count, I only have one PLAT badge.
But like, obviously, I'm a multiple PLAT player.
I have a lot of bronze badges cause I was really bad at one point.
And then I improved to PLAT.
At one point?
Yeah.
Specifically, there's one point where you were bad?
No, no.
I literally have like six plus bronze badges.
Do you actually?
I've heard you have flags though.
I kind of want them.
I do.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
How do I go see my badges?
Check out my stream right now.
Check it out.
Don't worry.
I thought of this too.
People were like, wait, she's not PLAT.
Don't worry.
I am PLAT cause I put my badges on.
All that matters is you got the badge on accounts.
Yeah.
We'll be sharing the first usable legends here soon.
Okay, cool.
Alright, nice.
I didn't mean to cut you off.
You're streaming on Twitch.
I was like...
Yeah, of course.
It's Twitch Rivals.
Why would I be streaming on Twitch?
I don't know.
It's literally Twitch Rivals.
Alright, let me put you... whoa.
Let me add you on the screen here.
Damn.
You got some nice bronze badges.
Yeah.
You like it?
You know I improved as a gamer.
Cause like, I went from bronze to PLAT.
I'm at my peak!
I'm at my peak right now.
Yeah!
Codes out!
Alright, I need to apparently raise up...
It's alright.
I'm not going to be the last person joining in anyway.
It'll be fine.
I can like... Okay, wait.
Ready?
We have our...
We have our comp here.
List of legends from map one.
Okay?
Fuse, Mad Maggie, Horizon, Revenant, Bloodhound, Rampart, Watson, or Gibraltar.
Wait, can you repeat that?
That's a lot of people.
Assault.
Okay.
Assault is going to be Fuse, Mad Maggie.
Oh, I can read it.
Skirmisher is going to be Horizon, Revenant.
Recon is going to be Bloodhound.
Controller is going to be Rampart, Watson, and then the last one is Gibraltar.
Okay, we clearly need like a a ring reader, so...
We need somebody to read the ring and we're going to survive here.
That's what people are probably going to do.
They're probably going to go Horizon, Blood, Watson, maybe?
Yeah, you know all the pros are going to take blood.
Okay.
You're going to run everything down.
Yeah, Wig.
Our captain.
Yeah, you're going to run everything down.
Yeah, right?
Right, Wig?
Oh, hell no.
I'm not playing.
What?
What do you mean, Wig?
You're clearly our captain pro.
It says...
It says captain pred pro.
Are you trying to say you're not professional?
Did you lie on your resume?
You lied on your resume.
Yes, of course.
My LinkedIn was a complete fucking lie.
I shouldn't even be here in the first place.
Fake it till you make it, I guess.
So are you playing Fuse?
Tempo?
No, we need somebody for control.
If Tempo wants to play Fuse, I'll play Bloodhound.
I'll take the L.
Yeah, that's fine.
Okay.
That's great.
And then I guess I'll play Watson then.
So we're playing Watson, Bloodhound, Fuse?
Fuck it, dude.
Lock me in.
I'm shutting down.
We need somebody to read the ring.
I mean, no, I agree.
Yeah, you're right.
We're starting off on World's Edge, so I play Geyser.
So we're Geyser.
Sorry, that's not the best POI.
You gave us Geyser?
I know, I panicked.
You're literally the fucking headliner.
You can request for any fucking POI.
I know, I panicked so bad.
And then we have Tempo that can kick off any pro player off the scrims.
I know, I know.
If they try to contest us.
I know, I got scared.
I said abuse your power, not be a bitch.
Oh, but I'm always a bitch, man.
I'm always a bitch, bro.
Oh, I was always a bitch, man.
What happened to you, man?
What happened?
I've been this way.
We had to go back to childhood.
I don't know.
That was some emotional trauma.
How long ago...
How long ago did I become a little bitch?
Yeah, become a little fucking bitch.
I mean, Geyser's...
Realistically, Geyser's not awful.
It isn't.
No, it's pretty awful.
No, you guys are just coping now.
Does the flying thingy still go through Geyser?
What?
The what thing?
The ball thingy.
The evac?
What the fuck is the ball?
What is the ball?
The flying ball.
The drone that flies with the ball.
What?
Why am I forgetting what that is?
Is that the loot tick?
Are you talking the loot balls?
Is that it?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Guys, I'm just...
Not bottom five.
That's my goal.
What do you mean, not bottom five?
Oh my god.
He watches Apex every day and said the loot ball thingy, dude.
No, the loot tick is the...
The cargo bot.
Yeah, the loot tick is the thing with the legs.
Yeah, cargo bot.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, but he said the ball thingies.
Yeah, it's a ball we're playing.
He said it as if it's like something we fucking take.
Like a fucking...
The towers.
Oh my god.
Okay, the lobby is open.
I'm heading in.
Guys, we're gonna...
Not bottom five.
I'm actually not gonna use charge rifle and no one will run at us.
Let's go.
Okay, how good are you with the sentinel?
Bro.
Can we just run three snipers and just go somewhere high and then just try and snipe people and get kills that way?
And just make everyone angry?
Okay, we just...
The way to get to that area is that we have to make sure we don't dive to travel there first.
We have to make sure...
Well, no Valk is gonna be our crutch here.
We're fucked.
We have no Valk.
Remember, we need three evac towers.
Well, last time we played...
Well, actually, no, we didn't play.
But last time, you know...
That's when you and Tempo played.
I would say that we had Valk because we literally needed it.
Now we don't have it.
But no one else has Valk, too.
We're playing without Valk or an evac tower.
Okay, so at this point, we just gotta hope RNG are... Wait, wait, wait.
You have connections to Saff, right?
Can they...
Just spawn some evac towers in front of us?
Grieg just came to my chat.
Grieg just came to my room and said, if Tempo kills me, I'm pulling the fucking Ethernet cable.
So, Tempo, if you kill him, bro, my Internet goes out.
Yeah, but his Internet goes out, too.
He fucks over his phone.
Wait, what?
But you can go over to his room and pull his as well.
I can't pull out...
I can't pull out Hal's Internet.
You can pull... Okay.
Tell Hal...
I'm in the house alone.
I can't pull out anyone's Internet.
No, you...
Wait.
Oh, wait.
How...
Does any TSM member live with you?
They all do, but no one's here.
No, no, but...
You can be like...
Just log in on his computer and then it'll just disconnect him.
No, no, no.
Threaten their PCs.
I'm gonna install Destroyer 2009 on your PC if you kill me.
Okay.
To be fair, I was gonna say, like, throw their PCs out, but you can do that.
Oh.
That's true.
Keep this mad for their PCs.
Threaten their PCs.
You literally have their, like, babies right now.
That's, like, the way to go.
Hold their PCs hostage.
Exactly!
Someone in my chat said hold their PCs hostage.
For first place.
Oh my god, we're cooking.
Oh my god.
Someone... I'm so happy I didn't listen to any of that and just... I literally come back to, we're cooking.
So I just know that was an absolute shitshow of words that I shouldn't have heard.
No, we're discussing about how Tempo should hold TSM PCs for hostage.
So it'd be like, your PC's gonna get ransomware if you kill us.
Holy fuck.
Bro!
They're gonna be so scared!
They wouldn't wanna kill us after that!
We're gonna do so well, guys.
I... not bottom five.
That's all I ask for.
Bottom five?
No, no.
No way it's bottom five.
There's no way.
There's no way!
And if we do get bottom five, the system hated us for... we were too good to play their games.
No, listen.
I'm gonna tell you right now.
You guys, listen.
I have the right to... Are you sipping something or laughing?
No, I'm sipping.
She's just laughing at you.
I was like, this is gonna be a serious game.
Now, here, listen.
I can get us where we need to be.
Okay.
Okay, how?
That... I don't know yet.
We're gonna figure it out.
Okay, okay.
Okay, I thought you figured it out already.
We don't have a Valk.
A Valk was really easy for me to get us to where we need to be.
But, I'm telling you, if we get there, I think Tempo's gonna pop off.
I'm serious here, too.
I'm not lying.
Okay, how much you wanna bet?
We don't have to bet anymore.
No, no, no, no.
I wanna know where the money is.
Like, how much you wanna bet?
I'll bet you a second blended Subway sandwich.
We didn't do the first one.
I can't trust you on that.
You didn't do it either.
I was waiting for you.
Technically, I'm free from that already.
Technically, Donkey Bird didn't promise.
Donkey Bird didn't promise a blended Subway.
I'm just saying.
I'll gift you five subs that Tempo gets.
Well, actually, how many kills though?
That's how much you believe in him.
Five subs.
That's how much.
His life is worth five subs.
That's like how many dollars.
Don't gaslight me.
You're playing on his downfall.
You're saying he's so bad.
No, I wanna know how much you believe in him.
But, clearly, you don't believe in him enough if it's worth five subs.
Alright.
Yeah, you couldn't be more right.
100%.
Yeah.
No offense, Tempo.
I love you to death.
I'm not gonna sit here and say he's gonna get like ten kills.
I think Tempo gets like five in six games.
I can't believe... I can't believe he's... Like, if he gets a kill, it's gonna be on a pro player.
So you're trying to say that his pro player kills aren't even worth more than one sub per kill.
There we go.
It's not even worth one.
Wait, we're playing...
Only allowed legends is Fuzi, Mad Nagi, Horizon?
Wait, what?
Revenant Bloodhound.
Oh, there they're going.
Okay.
Yeah.
Bro, you mean...
You're trying to say Tempo is worth like $25 in kills?
Correct.
Bro!
Watch this.
If I had to pay Tempo to be on my team for $25, I'd pay him $25.
What are the odds someone ends up with negative points today?
Who's to learn?
Wait, say it again?
Say that again.
Who the fuck is that guy?
Who the fuck?
I don't know who the fuck Shalen is.
Yeah, I'm Doki.
Yeah, what are you talking about?
It's my first time being Doki.
Yeah.
Okay.
Five subs.
If Tempo does... Wait, wait.
What was the deal?
If Tempo gets like one kill, it's five subs.
Holy shit.
One kill, five subs?
No, no.
Doki's making...
I didn't say that.
I can get a hundred subs here.
Yeah, okay, okay.
If Tempo gets one kill, you have to gift me and Tempo five subs each.
Oh my god.
Imagine Destroyer actually gets in his lobby.
Also, if he doesn't, you have to gift me five subs.
Alright, down.
That's fine.
I'll deal.
Okay.
Deal.
Alright.
I don't know how I always get wrapped in these things with you, but it just matters.
It's fine.
Yeah!
We did it!
Of course you did it.
You do it every time.
You're so good at it.
You're so convincing.
That's insane to say!
How am I a little bitch, bro?
I'm a bitch for believing in my friends?
Now you don't agree that you're a little bitch?
You literally told me you've been a little bitch since you were young.
I'm believing in my friends.
See?
You literally told me.
You literally told me you've been a little bitch since you were in sixth grade.
Or since you were six.
And now you're not?
No.
Actually, today's the day I change.
I'm not a little bitch anymore.
Today's the day you change.
After giving us Geyser as a drop spot, today's the day you change.
Hey!
Listen!
I got Command Center.
That's pretty fucking good.
Alright?
For the next map.
I got that.
Maybe I am still a little bitch.
Holy shit.
Hey!
Listen.
All I'm saying is I'm gonna do this.
Drop Geyser.
Ready?
Look at me.
Yeah.
Banned from tourney.
Oh, fuck.
I spelled tourney wrong.
FYI.
At knock.
Yeah, let him know.
Cause knock's thinking about where free kills are now.
I guarantee it.
Okay, just be like...
And then he's licking his lips.
Just be like, if you kill us, Wig isn't gonna watch part of your team.
They might be thankful for that.
Oh, shit.
No.
You will watch their team if you kill us.
Wig's gonna watch your team.
No one should drop on us.
I told them they don't get any DC restarts that they do.
Oh my god.
You're a genius, bro.
Nice.
You're a genius.
Hold them hostage.
Fuse.
Nice.
Oh, yeah.
Hold them hostage.
The only free skin I got.
Who am I going again?
Um.
Bloodhound.
Yeah, you're a role player.
And you're going Watson.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm going Watson.
We're already.
We didn't get negative five.
So, that's good.
Yeah, we're doing it.
If someone goes negative, we have to be mean to them.
Yeah, we have to be mean to them.
We have to be mean.
Yeah, yeah.
Just spam who's negative five right now.
Who are we restarting for?
You gotta be mean to them.
Here we go.
We got this.
I can't beat Jump Master.
Okay.
Wow.
Alright.
Where am I landing?
Pass it to the little bitch, I guess, dude.
Yeah, the little bitch who's captain.
Yeah, yeah.
Little baby.
We're trying to build up your confidence.
That's why I'm giving you Jump Master.
You just called me a bitch like forty times, though.
Yes, but if you cry about it, then you are... Now you can build it back up.
Yeah.
After she brought it down.
What doesn't kill you makes you stronger.
You're so right.
Yeah.
Words will never hurt me.
Exactly.
Only in high school.
It really hurt in high school.
We're not gonna get contested, right?
There's no way to contest this.
It's fucking dicey.
I'm not gonna leave in the game.
It's like, what the fuck do you want Geyser for?
It's literally the shittiest drop ever.
Oh, I should have went No Name.
I'm just gonna go through the tunnel.
So they don't take my loot.
I'll go through the tunnel.
Okay.
We have no beacon.
Yeah.
We're off to a good start.
We could go to Overlook and get it.
Wait, there's Gents killing more.
Oh, it's not fucking anonymous mode.
Yeah.
It's okay.
Don't restart it.
We're fine.
That's one less team to worry about.
True, actually.
I'll tell them to put it on for the next game, to be honest.
Alright.
They didn't have it on during what's it called either?
The Asia Festival, right?
I don't remember.
I don't think it's common to have it on for Asia, isn't it?
I think you're right.
It's been a while since I played Asia tournaments.
We can grab two charge rifles, Wig.
You already have one?
Do not listen.
To the dark comments in your mind.
Let's be the most annoying team in the game.
Do not listen.
I don't have a backpack, bro.
Okay, we're off to a really, really good start.
No, no, no.
It means you're gonna grab a...
You'll get purple backpack later on in life.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Next game.
Next game you'll get a...
Okay.
Here's this.
Okay, guys.
Thank God we don't have the...
the armors left on the floor because I don't think we were ever gonna find armors in Geysi.
No, we were probably gonna get just triple white anyway.
Yeah.
There's no difference now.
Geysi was like... Yeah, Geysi was pretty bad.
It's not like awful.
No, it's fucking awful.
What do you mean?
Yeah, it's pretty awful.
Well, if the little drone is flying by, it's okay.
Yeah, you can shoot the drone.
Do we have a Valkyrie?
No.
No?
Why would you think we have...
The little drone did not come this way.
Who didn't ping it three times?
Tempo.
It's really... It's really cute that you think we'll have anything.
It's...
Okay, wait.
Where do we go?
I'm trying to think.
We gotta craft up.
Craft a bat real quick.
I have nothing.
You guys have stuff?
I'm gonna craft... I didn't.
I'm gonna craft a bat right now.
We have four bats.
I can craft an extra bat for you.
Let me... Okay.
I'm gonna hit this raven and just see where people are going.
So we're not getting routed.
Wait, they might be routing that tunnel.
I think I might have saw someone.
One sec.
Okay, cause I'm crafting this.
If I get shot, I will craft it.
Nah, we're good.
We're good.
Chillin'.
I still don't have a backpack.
It's crazy.
Here.
Here's a bat.
Nice.
I'm pretty sure I saw a white backpack.
Maybe.
Alright, we should try to rotate to where a beacon is.
Where is beacon?
Well, big mod's probably still over there.
So I don't know if I want to go that way.
Oh, thank you.
See, look at that.
Siphon's pretty shit.
I mean, we could just rotate it with a siphon, but there might be multiple squads rotating in that way.
There's no siphon side.
Let's just start walking up.
Alright, I believe in you.
I don't have a new guy's tower.
Is anyone in?
Nope.
We are in an awful spot for our rotation.
There's a pack right there.
I don't know if...
Alright, who's gonna get it?
Look at all of us.
Let's start moving up.
Wait, there's like two.
Yeah, let's do that.
Alright.
How are we still on?
We're very...
We're very not so good.
Right now.
Alright, I'm gonna go get it cause... Alright, I'm gonna cover you.
Alright, I'm watching with the charge rifle.
I am putting fences behind us.
Okay, I'm dead guys.
This is a really good try.
Okay, that's fine.
I'm so fucked.
The one is blue armored.
That's okay.
We're so fine.
They're dropping down, guys.
They're dropping down.
They're heading to that area.
I forgot what that area is called.
Okay, I got an R301.
Suck it, bitch!
Yeah, fuck him up!
Tempo!
Tempo, go Tempo, go!
I'm dead.
We're gonna reload.
I'm reloading, I'm reloading.
Are they moving through?
They already crossed over that, yeah.
Are they in the building?
I don't know.
They ran back into Syphon.
Okay, I'm gonna just come up and scan cause we should try to get one of these buildings and move in from there.
I'm gonna scan one sec.
We're right behind you.
Yeah, come up, come up.
Nice job, Tempo.
Oh my god, Tempo's doing it!
I have 12 nades.
If we can just trap someone somewhere...
If we can just trap someone...
Let's shit loose.
I mean, I have a gold R301, realistically.
No matter how bad I am.
13 nade.
We wanna keep moving in a little bit though cause I don't see anyone posted up here at all.
We wanna keep moving.
We're gonna keep moving.
I'm just gonna keep scanning so we don't get routed on.
Alright, I'm right behind you.
Guys!
We're not 20th!
No, that's huge for us.
We're making waves!
It was Keon.
It was fucking Keon.
Ah, what?
No, no, no.
There was, there was, there was.
I think Halcon.
Oh my god.
I don't think this whole side's looted though.
That makes me definitely think it's towards...
Definitely, this is not...
I have 12... I have 20 shield cells.
Alright, we need to go middle.
We need to take this gondola across.
Alright.
I mean, we have... Oh, there's a ring council!
Yeah, that's where we're gonna go hit.
There was a team here 30 seconds ago.
Get in the house!
I mean, car.
What the house?
We're gonna get in the house over here.
If there's a team here, just stay on the gondola.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can stick them with my arc.
Okay, someone protect me while I do the ring council.
Yeah, this is extremely sketched, but I think we should...
Yeah, I mean, if I die, you can craft me.
Wait, we don't have anybody to craft.
Okay, never mind.
I'm just dead.
Okay.
I'm pretty sure we're like the only team that has white armor right now.
There's no fucking way.
No, no, no, we're good.
Wait, what if we grab the fucking...
There's a team over here.
We can right now.
We're gonna go do it right now.
Why didn't we grab the cash right behind us?
I don't need any evil cash.
I'm blue, bitches.
That's all you, buddy.
I'm getting this cash for sure.
I'm going with Tim.
I'm going with Wig just in case we get...
I charge rifled him from 450 meters.
We love that for you.
Nice shot, buddy.
I'm so proud of you.
Don't worry, guys.
I am still gonna fence this up.
I'm on our roof.
Dude, another team flew in there.
I'm gonna fence this up, guys.
I'm doing it.
You're playing in this building?
We gotta move up now.
We're gonna move up a little bit more.
We can't really move right now anyway because there's...
We're stuck.
We're stuck, Stepbro.
I wanna go through, like, launch.
But, again, we don't have no evac towers.
I don't think we're ever gonna find evac towers.
No, I know.
This is so fucked.
I don't think so, guys.
I got one!
Oh!
Go, Tempo!
I've always believed in you.
That's five stops.
Tempo, Tempo, where is it?
Tempo!
What the fuck are you doing?
What the fuck?
Oh my god, Tempo!
I just got fucking rocked.
Dive!
Dodge!
I'm safe.
Bro, I'm covering.
I got a kill.
That's five subs!
It was on the bridge.
Five subs already?
That's five subs to Tempo, five subs to me.
That's ten subs.
That's insane.
Alright, we need to go command center.
We need to get the fuck out of this position.
Alright, I can charge.
I can scan again.
Okay, let's believe it.
There's no way someone's gonna shoot me, right?
There's no way.
I'm watching, I'm watching.
There's a team on south.
A team just fenced up south.
That's fine, that's fine.
We can just play in here for right now.
I'm trying to find an evac.
Can I play in the middle, up here?
Realistically, us getting out of this situation with that one is like...
Zero brewing.
Yeah, we need... unless like everybody suddenly collides with each other.
Let me get the south team.
With my charge rifle.
Alright.
Just in case.
We're good, yeah, just fence up.
Nice job, Toki!
Look at me go!
I'm fencing!
Look at you go!
I'm contributing to the team.
Hell yeah, we're alive.
That's also a W.
I'll take not 20th all day, every day.
I'm being so serious.
Shit on, kid.
We're okay.
Everything will be fine.
No, we're fine.
No one's north, no one's middle.
I just realized, bro, my fucking...
We all have...
Wait, you guys got purple and blue backpacks?
How did I end up with a white backpack?
Oh wait, I have a blue backpack.
I have a fucking wig.
Realistically, like, RV down here wouldn't be bad.
I just don't know how the fuck we get there.
How was I the one to end up with the shittiest backpack out of all of you?
There's a team on bridge, isn't there?
Fuck me.
I'm gonna go away.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The team on bridge is the one I gotta knock on.
Can we get underneath this platform if we run?
Right now?
I mean, I don't know when else we're gonna do it.
I feel like... I mean, it's very risky.
That's for sure.
Yeah, it definitely is risky.
I don't think there's anyone on our right, though.
At least we have a rotational spot later.
We can't... I don't want to play blue bins because we're gonna go against the Gibraltar team who's gonna ult us.
I have all...
Do we have full kill?
They're not rez'd?
Did you knock the team on the left?
Well, we don't know who exactly...
I killed a team on the bridge.
Yeah, but they might have rez'd because they have a rez beacon.
Is the rez beacon activated?
Yeah, they definitely rez'd.
It's activated.
I was gonna say, if we kill the team on the left, then we can go there.
Okay, but guys, we can scan again.
Loki could.
Well, actually, let's go back and do it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's really no negative.
Exactly.
We can do one last...
Gibraltar, random Gibraltar on you.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, he's downstairs.
He's running away.
Hit the beacon.
Okay, okay, okay.
I got really scared.
Hit the beacon and run back to me immediately because they're above you.
Okay, that is not very...
I don't have a lot of confidence, but here we go.
One dropped down.
They went low ground, I think.
Yeah, they're low ground over here.
You're good.
We're still healthy.
I still don't know...
I did not see the Gibraltar at all.
We need to get underneath, brothers.
Wait, wait, wait.
We have no evac.
You got a full kill.
Tempo is the GOAT.
Oh, he's got 10 subs each!
We need to move, we need to move, we need to move.
Okay, that's 10 subs each person.
Come over here, we're gonna come over here and play this.
Oh my god.
I have 12 nades.
Okay, you're gonna set up your gen right here, Ducky.
Right here?
Okay, right now?
Actually, wait, don't do that yet.
I want to see if we can get an RV.
If there's no one in an RV, we should get there underneath.
Tempo, you think you could, like, fuse ulti these guys up here on the bridge that we run for RV?
Yeah, let me find their wads and gen.
Okay, I'm gonna keep fencing.
I destroyed it.
Wait, there's a fuse queue somewhere.
Oh, Jesus.
We're fine, we're fine, we're fine.
We're still fucking fine.
Yeah, we're good, we're good, we're good.
We just need to get in zone more, which sucks.
Yeah, we're just at the...
I don't even think we're in zone.
Wait, what the fuck?
Bro, I'm fucking setting this up.
Yeah, shut up, shut up, they're pushing, they're pushing.
They are?
Okay, I'm kidding, I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
I'm a shot from the team in front of us.
Yeah.
Okay, I'm good, I'm good, I'm good here.
I'm good now, I'm good now.
Alright.
I don't see him.
Wait, I think they want to push us in the back.
I'm checking.
Okay, they're not, they're not, they're not, they're not.
They're shooting like this.
Jen, go down, it's okay.
It's pretty annoying, actually.
They're leaving, they're leaving, they're gone.
Alright, we need to go to RV now, we need to jump down, this is really bad for us actually.
Yeah, we don't have...
No, he doesn't have it anymore.
Can you cue them?
We're gonna move left, we're gonna move left, come up.
I only have that one cue.
We're good, we're good, come down.
We're so healthy, we're so good, we're so good.
Oh, we are not...
No, no, no, no, protect that, protect that.
Oh, keep blocking that, keep blocking that.
We're so healthy.
Yeah, you're good, you're good.
We're not in zone, but we're so healthy.
I'm not in zone, but you're good, you're good, you're gonna play without me.
You're not in zone?
Okay, that is all I needed to know.
That's fine, that's fine, we're okay, no kill kill me, what a piece of shit.
You guys are good, man.
I had a Moby on my death box, by the way.
Get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, I can get it and raise him here.
Okay.
You probably could actually, you got this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, get it, get it, get it.
Temple, I believe in you.
The zone doesn't hurt as much.
Did you get the...
He did not get the Moby.
Okay, okay.
We're good, we're good.
We're fine, we're fine.
Let me shoot these guys up here.
I'll rez, I'll rez, I'll rez.
I'm looking up on the bridge, I don't see them.
I think we're okay, bro.
How are we not getting looked at right now?
Don't take this wig!
Free KP over here!
We're good, we're good.
I'm just kidding.
Don't worry, my fences will protect us.
Alright, we need to get in that corner.
They're fighting on bridge.
You guys should go to RV right now.
RV, RV, RV, let's go, let's go, let's go.
Go, go, go, without me.
They can't, they're not watching.
They're watching now, they're watching now.
Someone's inside, someone's inside RV.
What do you mean he's in the RV?
He's flashed, RV is flashed.
He's dead, dead, dead.
No, we lost him, but that's okay.
Okay, we have a strat here though.
We have a strat, one sec.
We're gonna get in this corner over here.
You still have your mobi if you looted your body.
I didn't loot it, I didn't loot it.
He didn't loot his body.
I couldn't loot anything.
Wait, does that guy have a body?
No, no.
Okay, we have a plan, I'm not even kidding.
We have a plan.
We're gonna get into this corner, come here.
Come, come, come, come, come.
Come to me.
We're so good, we're healthy.
That's a good placement.
I might die now because I hesitated.
Oh my god, don't be a little bitch.
I hesitated, I hesitated.
There's no way.
There's no way there was a full team.
It didn't matter.
There was a full team.
We're on the other side of the rock.
If we get there, we're vibing.
Oh my god.
Not a single evac.
What are we supposed to do?
It's okay, we got three kills.
We got three kills.
Four points.
Four points is actually not bad.
Four points is like the 10th place area.
We're good.
And also, no stand.
No evac.
That's pretty good.
Of course I got a fucking pyro howl.
Tempo, go over there and hold his PC hostage right now.
Tempo, run in there bro and summon his monitor immediately.
Run over there, take his monitor, show it on stream, and give Hal a message.
Snipe down, killed you, and Hal.
I got a tag team, bro.
I got Eiffel Tower'd by the fucking XTSM.
Guys, we got four kills and we didn't die 20th.
That's all that matters.
I'm not gonna lie, that was pretty good.
Yeah, that was pretty good with the situation we were in.
Yeah, that situation was pretty terrible.
Yeah, that was pretty terrible.
Pretty fucking terrible.
I feel like that's what we say every time.
That was like really bad for us, but we did kinda good.
That's what we say.
That's like our motto.
Okay, Tempo, how many kills you got?
We got a lot.
He got two kills, so that's ten subs each.
Fuck me.
Yeah, pay up.
Oh shit, I'm torched.
Oh my god, my moderator's still alive.
W.
Your moderator?
Yeah, he is.
Alucard, he's the coach.
Okay, if he has a higher placement than us, he should give us some of his prize winnings.
Alright, I'm back.
That's how it works if I don't pay him to be my mod.
But I still take a percentage of his winnings.
Our money now.
That's exactly how Twitch works.
Lowkey!
We're still alive.
Oh sweet, still alive of course.
And the prize is Kha Klan just going crazy.
This is so funny.
Only, I think if we had zone in any way, we definitely would have lived longer.
Oh no, if we had zone, we could have like went to lava siphon, took balloon, you know what I mean?
Yeah, we would have been so healthy.
I wanted to get that RV pretty bad.
We got that RV earlier where we could have killed an RV.
Yeah, but we sort of lost somebody.
Noko, he came out of the RV solo.
Bro, I thought Noko was there.
I didn't realize anyone was there.
And I'm just nading the bridge.
And then a Noko just comes out.
And then...
I have to mark him.
Bro, the guy was so confident.
I thought it was a full team, so I went to the side.
No, I mean, we did it.
We obviously did a good job.
We got in there and killed him.
Realistically, I should have got a kill on the Gibraltar up top too.
I almost one killed him like for like a thousand levels.
Probably the only time I'll have a good shot today.
It's okay.
This is our peak, guys.
This is the best gameplay you're going to see out of all of us.
This is the start of the damage.
We get plus one kill after every game.
Which means...
There's no way we can be last because...
Nothing kills game six.
There's no way we can be last because we already started out strong with kills.
I don't know why.
I was hoping someone would mis-pick a legend.
And they'd get minus five.
And then they'd get like bottom five.
And then their scoreboard is just negative.
Did anyone mis-pick a legend?
There must have been one person.
They said they were going to restart if...
Bro, what the fuck, babies?
20 teams up.
59 players alive.
Okay, nice.
We didn't restart.
I mean, not nice.
Not nice.
They're already two people over advantage.
It's called survival of the fittest.
We were able to...
We were able to connect.
We were able to evolve to what we are.
We didn't survive the fittest.
I did not do this tournament so ImperialHow can make more money.
He's buying me dinner.
You should not invite him.
That would go so well.
Thank God.
We'll take second place.
Wait, wait.
It's like everybody's invited except for Hal.
That was like...
Having those comps were kind of fun.
I kind of like seeing the legend.
That was a good time.
I can't believe I got hit with a sentinel and then a repeater when I died like that.
That was so fast.
I don't know.
I feel like even if I trusted you, Wig, we would have still died.
They won't.
I don't know.
Even if I trusted you and we ran at the same time...
You would have still died.
I don't know because I got...
Yeah, probably.
They were already heading towards you.
They were.
Yeah, Hal scanning a duo is just...
It's GG's.
I think he just literally started foaming out of his mouth.
He was so ready for it.
He scans us and he just swipes us for sure.
Damn you, Tempo.
My god.
That's fucking awesome.
Who was charge rifling?
Who was it?
It was me.
I'm going to take credit.
Oh no.
Peep got DC'd?
Fuck, that sucks.
We didn't restart?
Did I ask for a non-mode or does it not matter?
No, it doesn't really matter.
No, no.
Don't ask for it.
It'll be more fun.
I already did it.
I need to go to their channels and clip them raging.
Oh my god.
I need to know who I'm killing.
His little YouTube compilation.
He's going to make the pros rage at me.
Apex Legends compilation.
You won't believe which pro got angry at me.
I'm going to help you with the clickbait titles.
You're so good at that.
Did we get our subs?
Oh, they announced it?
Okay.
Oh, I can do catalyst.
I'll do the controller.
Oh wait, they announced the legends?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Valk, Seer, Newcastle, and Conduit.
Because Doki is going cat.
Yeah.
We have Valk!
Wait, wait, wait.
That means you can take Octane and I'll take Valk.
Do we trust Temple or Valk?
What is that?
Wait, who played Valk when we played last time?
That was me.
You played Watson and Doki played...
Well, yeah, Doki played...
What did I play?
Bang.
Oh, yeah, but Bang's nerfed, right?
Yeah, she's not bad though.
Wait, isn't the Bang smoke something something?
You said two words, and then the words that mattered was not there.
Did something change?
I just don't know what the something was, okay?
A lot of things changed, Temple.
You gotta be more specific.
Alright, my brain is telling me I should play Valk when my heart is saying Octane.
You should listen to your brain.
The times you've listened to your heart.
Oh, you're still right.
My heart told me to pick you guys, and my brain was like, what the fuck are you doing?
So maybe I should have listened to my brain in that situation.
We're not last place.
Just so you know, your heart picked us.
You're right.
My heart did pick you guys, which is the right choice.
Octane next game, who are you guys playing?
Then I'll take Valk.
Wait, next game, okay.
And then I'll do Catalyst.
Yeah, you can do Bang, whoever you're comfortable with.
Alright, I'll do Catalyst.
We need zone readers.
Yeah, this could be a good zone.
When I am the rational one in this team, that's when you know things are bad.
Oh wait, my Valk has a...
No, it's the challenges.
My Valk is locked.
Wait, has Valk...
Did I give you 10 subs yet?
No, I'll do it after.
Oh, okay.
Every time you get a kill, it's a plus 5.
Just remember that.
Temmo, he's going to literally fund your lifestyle.
Wait, what map are we on?
We're on Storm Point.
Storm Point?
Okay.
Storm Point we're going Command.
Can we get Valk gold out of that, right?
Yeah.
Oh, we're good.
We're so good.
We're so healthy.
I was trying to pick my Valk.
My skin.
Oh yeah, I need to pick my skins.
I'm trying to make it blend into the wall.
Okay, you're right.
I need to rearrange my badges.
Oh wait, my Valk badge.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was going to play...
I already forgot what I was playing.
Okay, banner.
Don't worry.
I'm going to make sure everybody knows what rank I'm in.
Oh, I almost queued up for rank.
I just want you to know, I have zero kills on Catalyst.
I think I also have zero.
Wait a minute.
Wait, wait, wait.
I was too busy with Jeb Burton.
What did you just say?
I have zero kills on Catalyst.
Zero cat kills.
I hate it.
And you chose Cat over Bang?
Yeah.
What is Cat's passive?
She can lock doors.
She can throw out the spikes.
She can lock the doors.
Lock the doors is crazy.
Yeah.
Technically it's locking doors.
And then she can put up a wall and and she looks slay while doing it.
She does look slay, to be honest.
I'm so happy Trick2G is playing, bro.
I used to watch Trick2G every day in League.
When I was an avid League player, I wanted to fucking cry every day.
That's who I watched.
Oh yeah, that's what I was going to say.
You played League.
I was going to say like, are you okay?
Are you okay?
Two years playing, Silver 2 Peak.
You're not out of the box.
Silver 2 Peak?
Yeah.
You're like that... oh wait.
I don't know if I can say it.
You're like that one guy that was Silver or something and he played League his whole career and then and then he tried to own an esport org.
You know, that guy.
Sam Baikman-Fried?
Yeah, the crypto dude?
He just got 25 years in jail.
Yeah, I saw that.
I was just sure we could talk about him because Tempo's here.
Oh, true.
Yeah, true.
What was the point called?
FTX?
FTX, yeah.
Hey Tempo, what was it called again?
Tempo, you remember that coin that had a deal with TSM?
Yeah.
That guy.
You know, the one that's been apparently bronze or whatever after 10 years of League.
So then he decided to own an esport org.
That guy.
Well, it's a good thing we could talk about it.
Yeah, you should be able to openly talk about this.
It's okay, Tempo.
That whole shit is actually crazy.
Yeah, I'm surprised.
Like...
I'm surprised he almost got away with it.
Until he got 25 years in prison.
I don't even know if that's enough though.
That was like the biggest heist ever.
Yeah.
He almost got away with it too.
And we went for this meddling kids.
I'm trying to pull that out again.
35 million.
35 years.
Yeah, he made an entire esport org to change their fucking name.
Yeah, and he also paid off for fucking, um...
There was like a basketball team, I think.
Oh yeah!
With crypto!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Crazy.
He did everything with that money.
That's actually insane.
He did everything with that money to actually do what he was supposed to do.
I'm back, guys.
We're in like ninth place.
We're top ten!
We're like tied for ninth.
There's like five people with four points.
Nice.
We got this.
Alright, wait, what?
What?
I was...
They started showing the standings and I was so invested to see where we were.
I completely zoned out.
That's good, that's good.
We were talking really great about TSM.
Oh, okay.
That's good.
Yeah, don't worry.
We're hyping TSM up.
So you won't get fired.
Never.
About that?
Hello?
Something you didn't tell us or what?
Whoa, Temple.
Temple, what happened?
Can I sleep on your couch?
I told you, bro.
Lan, my couch is yours.
What?
I got you on warm milk at night if you need.
Bro, was this before us?
Morning juice box and everything.
I got you, dude.
You'll actually be treated like a king in my apartment.
Holy shit.
He didn't have a blanket.
He had to use one of the pillows as a blanket.
I'm taking all your juvie.
Are they kicking you out of the house?
No.
This is for Twitch Rivals.
Are you going to LAN?
No.
Wait, is that in LA?
Yeah.
What date is it?
May 2nd.
Okay, that's like a far.
I still have time to think about it.
When am I going to be on your fucking B stream?
When can I roll up?
Literally roll up on an iPad?
Yeah, obviously.
You gotta actually buy one of those.
No, Tempo's gonna buy it for me.
Huh?
The most broke one out of the three?
I thought you had a plan.
Don't you have a million subs on YouTube?
No, no, no.
I'm not a million.
I'm a poor...
I'm very tiny.
I'm a very tiny streamer.
I just started a month ago, guys.
I just started a month ago.
Oh, so true.
You're brand new to this.
Yeah, I'm brand new.
I'm just a natural entertainer.
Good for you.
You didn't get the kill though, man.
What's wrong with you?
I don't know.
I have no idea.
He typed it, not me.
Also, I thought, Tempo, I thought you had the setup already.
Because you were going to do it on Last Land.
What happened?
I didn't buy it.
I didn't buy the roller coaster thing.
Of course you didn't buy it.
You didn't even buy it?
You literally told me like, Oh, TSA won't let me do it.
I have the iPad.
Yes, he has the iPad.
I have the tablet.
I need the rolly thingy with the wheels.
Ask EA to buy it.
We'll make it off as a business expense.
That is so smart.
We all have good connections with EA staff.
Yeah, let me go talk to Chen.
Yeah, we can literally convince them.
Because it's in LA instead of London.
So we don't have to get a plane.
We can return it to the respawn H2 actor.
Exactly, and then they can reuse it every time I want to butt in.
Oh.
You can playtest with the rolling iPad.
She's gonna fucking go straight into me.
Terrorize all the staff that are working.
We need to pay attention here.
We might be conned, guys.
We're gonna be conned?
We have no beacon.
Again?
What the fuck is the point of paying attention?
We have no beacon character.
Of course we have no beacon.
We didn't pick a control character.
We're just rolling.
No, I mean a map scan.
Oh, oh, wait.
Wait, there's someone like...
No, I'm Kallus.
Kallus can scan maps.
Yeah, you are.
You're literally the fucking casting.
I'm watching, I'm watching, I'm watching.
You watch so many Apex streams that you still don't know who's the controller.
I forgot you were on Tat, bro.
I forgot.
Oh my gosh, we have the...
Don't you forget it.
Where are you guys?
I'm so confused.
I have a jump tower, guys.
We're so set.
On me, on me, on me.
Wait, what?
I told you, I knew it.
We're actually getting contested?
No way I'm getting contested in my own tournament.
Yeah, what the fuck, they saw us.
That fucking command?
I see one all the way up there.
We wanna get height, that's the problem here.
Wait, can we just not...
Can we not take this now?
No, I don't think we can.
They're covering it.
Bro, they're taking it right now.
My audio's off.
Your audio?
My audio's back on.
You have no audio?
Where's someone we can rotate to that has it?
I forgot I lowered my...
You didn't ping the charge rifle.
I'm sorry, I was a little bit confluxed.
He's at 6x.
Oh, 6x.
Oh, I'm rich!
Alright, I don't have...
Alright, they're leaving.
We're gonna go over to where they were.
And we're gonna go on the zip line again.
We wanna take height, we definitely do.
I'm right behind you.
If anything happens...
That's fine, thank you.
If anything happens, we can not craft you.
Cause we don't have that.
They're still here.
Did they shoot you, Tempo?
They shot you?
They're pushing this.
Go back, we don't wanna fight this.
Just leave.
Going through this door then?
Don't worry, I'm gonna lock the door.
I just don't know if the zone's going this way and we're gonna get ran at.
Cause the zone actually looks like it could be.
Let's take this house to our right side right now.
Alright.
I'd rather just be safe.
And just go to wall later.
We can grab the...
The cash thing after.
Yeah, I'm down.
Okay guys, I haven't played Catalyst in a while.
So how many spikes can I throw?
Back, back, back, back.
Yeah, just go down.
I'm just gonna...
I'm heading down.
We're so messy.
Why is there...
Oh shit, I just went straight up.
Don't die there, please.
Alright, we're gonna play for here right now and see what goes on.
We got the evil cash here as well.
Suck it.
There's definitely someone that could be posting up coming to us.
I'm locking the door.
Yeah, yeah, just shut up right now.
Fuck it.
We're getting hoed right now pretty hard.
And I'm locking this door.
These people do not like us apparently.
It sucks.
This guy is for this.
I am like not confident right now.
Wait, we got the evil cash, right?
Actually, we're not in like a bad spot regardless of where the sound goes.
So we should be fine.
But what about our loot?
Aw, yeah.
We can go over to wall after this and just probably get the evil cash.
I don't see...
Someone was shooting us from here, but I don't see them anywhere.
Yeah, I don't know either.
I have like no long range, so I'm just gonna...
Oh, there's a longbow here for anybody.
I would take that ammo.
I'm gonna run this then for long range.
I dropped a vault.
If anyone wants a vault.
I have a vault already.
This team is not staying on the height of that building which is making me think it's not going here.
Oh wait, someone just landed on top.
Yeah, it's making me think it is going over there, which is pretty good.
I think we just stay in this house then for now.
Yeah, let's just not waste any loot because we...
Don't have a lot of it.
Yeah, we're free.
We're pretty poor right now.
Anyone kind of like to donate loot to us?
Please, we need it.
Please.
If anybody stream sniping us.
Wait, Doki, do you have Qs at all?
Yeah, but...
Can you try to put one on the window just for the peek?
Oh yeah, sure.
Which one?
Here?
Wait, Iman, are you shooting someone that's going this way?
Alright.
That's not great.
Is that alright?
Yeah, for visual clutter it doesn't matter.
As long as it makes it...
Drop back down to...
You're not on height anymore.
I'm stressed, I'm stressed.
Where are you stressed out about?
We have good position.
We should loot, but like...
As long as they don't come in and kill us.
Covering a cell.
Yeah, only problem is we're just triple wiped.
If someone shoots that they're gonna be like, ooh.
Okay, then just don't get shot.
Wait, we're in the cure packs.
Can't we scan them?
I tried, I didn't look quick enough.
I'm an idiot.
Oh wait, they're fighting in cascades.
See if I can get a blue off of this.
Yeah, try to farm some shit.
Yeah, you farm for us.
We're just gonna be here.
Yeah, you get your shield up, buddy.
Yeah, you're our sniper.
I have four cells.
Okay, I have some here.
Oh my god, do you guys remember the strat that we were supposed to do last time?
Where like...
You know, remember the one where...
We let Tempo drop wherever the fuck he wants.
And then...
I do remember that one.
Let's go!
We never did that strat!
We didn't do that so bad.
We did that last game today.
We did that for...
Oh shit!
He's in that room!
Of course.
On roof, we're dead here.
We're so dead.
We need to go wall slot.
I'm leaving, I'm leaving.
I'm leaving.
We should have made tempo.
On top of the building, Tempo?
Yeah, he was, by the way.
Okay, they have no idea I'm here.
I'm dead.
Yes, it doesn't matter.
Drop got me.
I can't believe I'm standing here.
They're sending us.
They're pushing us.
You run, you run.
Let me die.
You shouldn't have been a hero!
Tempo won!
We got 20 in Tempo!
Tempo, we got...
Tempo, man!
We got last!
Tempo!
Wait, we're not center zone.
I'm not saying that.
In that zone, we were.
Oh, yeah.
Tempo!
20th place, bro.
And no beacon for us again.
Does this game hate us?
Okay, what if, like, in our third game, we let Tempo land?
We let Tempo go wherever the fuck he wants.
No, because this next game is Olympus.
And we have a good POI.
We have phase drivers.
We have infinite balls.
Infinite balls.
But what if we get contested?
No, we might get contested.
Yeah.
I mean, it's because people see our names.
Timmy is based there.
Oh, fuck.
We do not want to fight that guy.
Wait, what?
I thought you said we had good POI.
Dude, what is this shit?
What's going on?
Let me go find some...
Is there anyone that's free, Tempo?
Apex.
I can't believe it.
That was so tough, dude.
Super unfortunate.
Wait, this is why you don't follow your heart.
I mean, why am I getting contested at Command Center, bro?
You followed your heart and then we got 20th place.
At Command Center, no beacon and we're contested.
My strategy is just fucked out the window there.
Because the whole point is I wanted to get beaconed then Valko will come up there so we don't have to shoot for the rest of the game.
We just know exactly where to go.
Because Tempo is sitting on top of roofs.
No comment.
With his back...
Wait, I was shooting someone.
Yeah, but you shot... I got shot in the back.
I was shooting cascades and then I don't know where those guys came from.
And they were in the house next to us.
Alright, we'll shoot with these guys.
I found a map.
Did we get zero points?
It is zero points.
Yes, we were 20th.
I wasn't sure if we got a kill and Tempo worked some magic with that charge rifle.
I wasn't sure.
Get revenge.
No one's good.
Tempo, what's free?
What's free for the next map?
We're moving on.
Memory like a goldfish.
What's free?
Where's Oasis?
Oh, here it is.
Next.
What's free?
Do we have anything?
Is there...
We should...
Oh my god.
I have an idea.
If there's no spot free, we see who's the 20th place team and we land on them.
That's us.
No, I meant overall.
Overall.
Is that fucked up?
That's not fucked up, right?
No, no, no.
We're weak and we're playing on the weaker.
That's fair as fuck.
It's strategy.
If people can do that in pro league and fuck over other teams, we can too.
There's no rules against doing that.
Against sabotaging other teams.
Yeah.
Okay, so we just need to find out who's overall 20th place and then take their...
then take their POI.
I...
I don't know if we can even be 20th place.
There's no way.
I think we are the 20th in terms of gun skill.
No, no.
There's one open POI.
Turbine.
Oh, that's good.
Let's do it.
Let's get Turbine.
Say Turbine in chat, please.
Or, guys...
Or, we can get three points.
And land on the 20th team overall.
But here's the thing.
If we lose the 20th place team, what the fuck are we gonna do?
Then we're the 20th place team.
And then we become the 20th place team.
Oh my gosh.
Are you...
Do you not believe in us, Wei?
I believe in...
Okay, do you not believe in me?
No, no.
I believe in you.
You are a Plat 3 player, you know what I mean?
Yeah, yeah.
I'm pretty good for a Plat 4 player.
Yeah.
For a Plat 4 player, I'm pretty good.
If we get, like, Tempo not to die, we're good to go.
You know what I'm saying?
That's true.
Tempo got us two points last game.
Yeah, yeah.
That's the thing.
We need him to be alive to farm points for us.
We just need a...
You know why that happened?
Because I was on Valk and I was like, Oh, I can fly.
And then I flew to the roof.
This is why...
If I was...
If I was any other legend, I would not have been able to make it up on the roof.
And I'd be like, fuck it.
This is why you never listen to your heart.
I was trying to be a good teammate.
He was so excited to play Valk.
I don't know what to say.
To be a good teammate.
You seem that you're like, I want to play Valk.
No, because he wanted you to play Octane.
Tempo was the one that was trying to be a good teammate.
Realistically, realistically, we want to be honest here.
Tempo should be playing the controller characters.
Okay.
Okay, yeah.
I'll take all the controllers.
Unless there's a fuse.
Okay, wait.
Tell them not to add it.
Put fuse in?
Yeah, I might message them to say not to put fuse in.
Tell them to remove all fuses from now on.
Some of my chat says, you realize that Doki still has zero kills on cat?
Yeah, do you still have zero kills on cat after that game?
Zero kills on cat.
Yeah, dude.
Keeping that tradition.
We're so torched.
Why are there so many teams alive still?
I don't know.
That's because we died pretty early.
We didn't even get the Valk ulti that game.
We didn't even get any ulti.
Guys, 20th place in my own tournament is crazy.
This is crazy.
We have to get at least 19th next game.
We have to.
We're not improving.
What happened?
No one's contesting next game.
Guys.
That's already one thing we don't have to worry about.
That also means no one's going to die to me.
We should tell everybody what our skins are so they won't run at us.
Then we'll give them someone else's skin so they chase after them instead.
That is so true.
What is his team skins?
Yellow bang.
Bang.
I'm now a yellow bang.
I'll play yellow spins, I'm down.
Or bright yellow.
Or bright pink.
No, no, we're giving people wrong...
Wait, what map are we playing on?
We're giving people other people's skin colors.
My mom in the chat said, I'm back, what's happening?
Mom, we just got 20th place.
No, you could have lied.
She wouldn't know.
Mom, we got first.
We got first last game.
I think we're in...
We were doing so well that EA staff told us to sit this one out.
So other people can have a chance.
We're watch -partying from inside the game now.
I want to say right now that this is better than international scrims quality.
14 teams alive on board.
We have 14 teams alive after 12 seconds of the first game.
People don't get money from scrims.
Of course this is better.
You're so right, you're so right.
Money changes everything.
Even if they did.
Not for us though.
Not for us.
We're the content.
There's not changing anything for us.
We're literally content.
No, Temple, you should start giving vouchers for your scrims.
So people take it more seriously.
Like a $5 coupon for something.
A $5 coupon?
We'll gift you a sub.
We'll gift you 5 subs if you survive.
Pass round 3.
That's so true!
That's how we should do the payout.
Yeah!
Instead of overall placement, we should do 5.
Pass round 3.
For every round.
For every round you survive, your team earns extra money.
It earns like 5 subs.
Per person.
That would be financed by Wig.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Make the bank account for everybody.
Okay, but Wig, it'll give you better quality scrims, which means more viewers, more viewers in general, which means more income in general.
So in the end, you're gonna gain money in the end.
You're so smart.
Viewers would want to watch better scrims because the scrims would be longer too.
Yeah.
And then you can run as many ads as you want.
Sorry guys, I gotta run the ads now.
Doki has a fascination with me spending money.
She's like, listen, Tempo gets these kills, you just drop like 600 bucks each.
It's not that big of a deal.
It's motivation.
Money motivates people.
It's true.
Look at right now.
Look at the quality of this tournament.
Because of money.
This is the most motivated I've seen snipe down in a very long time.
Whoa.
Him not being relegated.
Him being relegated probably didn't help.
This is good.
He's playing like he's 10 years younger right now.
Oh yeah.
And his eyes.
And he just died.
And he gets beamed across the fucking map, dude.
You had to say regulated.
There is no fucking way, dude.
You just actually VTuber cursed him so hard.
You're the one that mentioned his name first.
What do you mean?
I was talking about getting money motivation.
But you're here.
You're here.
I'm here.
I give the extra curse.
Agreed.
There's gotta be something along with VTubers and curses.
They don't really make sense.
No, I think casters give a better curse than VTubers.
I will agree that I definitely give a harder curse.
Yeah.
For sure.
I'll agree with that one.
Holy shit.
This is a hard zone.
I'm gonna be honest, guys.
I'm kinda happy we died.
What do you mean?
No.
You're happy that we died 20th?
Yeah, a little bit.
Cause I don't think we would've We would've been on that house on the left side.
Uh huh.
We could've valked over there and got the house.
That would've been us.
I just... I think the Tempo's just a boss for that.
Just sitting on top of a roof like that is crazy.
Yeah, with white armor, that was actually crazy.
No, you're a piece of that.
Like, all confidence, white armor.
Did you not think you were on white armor?
I mean, I don't think it would help.
He was dead regardless if it was white or blue.
If I had blue, I would've been alive.
You were literally standing still, charged right?
Tempo, your reaction time on that was crazy.
How do you know?
You didn't see anything.
I looked up.
And you were still in the same spot.
I looked up and you were still standing still when you were getting shot.
What do you mean?
I don't know what you're talking about.
I'm talking about you, Tempo.
Jersey's off.
Are you taking off your fucking shirt right now on stream?
I'm ready.
The day I stop playing is the day Tempo plays in a tournament where he's shirtless.
Bro, he's shirtless right now.
Look at this.
Is that Toss?
Can you play with your titties out?
No, it'd be like those nipple stickers that they on Twitch.
People who do it on Twitch for body paint.
The pasties.
How do you know the name of that?
I've been doing it.
How do you know the name?
I used to watch makeup tutorials when I was younger.
All the time.
Really?
Wait, really?
Yeah, I was interested in makeup for a while.
Oh, shit.
So you had pasties on your nips?
No, I do not wear pasties.
Why not?
I'm fucking naked.
But you had a fascination.
No, I was just interested with makeup.
I was like, oh, these people are good at it.
Okay, if you put that as a goal, What, to wear pasties on the street?
What, to wear pasties on the street?
There is not a single goal that would get me shirtless with nipple tassels on my fucking skin.
No, not like tassels, but just cover it as if you have no nipples.
I would actually rather have tassels than anything else you have.
Wait, wait, why would you not want to be nipple-less?
I don't want to see what I look like like that.
Oh my god, someone said you could make them spin.
That's what I'm saying.
Alright, we're back.
What do you mean we're back?
We've been here the whole time.
I want to go grab...
Wait, are you actually shirtless right now?
No.
Bro, no balls.
No balls is crazy.
No.
Hey, wait.
Oh no, he's dead.
Oh god, who's winning?
Just tell me who is winning.
Well, not Drop's team.
We just saw him got mowed down there.
He got rocked.
You gotta make sure I'm anonymous next game.
Why?
This is more fun.
Jen Burner's team won.
Of course he did.
Of course.
Wait, so you wouldn't...
Why wouldn't you wear Pacey's?
Why are you afraid of being nipple-less?
I don't understand, Wig.
I just don't want to see what I look like without it.
I don't know.
I'm down.
I'm trying to do it on stream.
I'm not trying to be like, no nipples on stream.
I'm not even trying to show my nipples on stream.
But it's not against TOS.
No, I fully understand it's not against TOS.
I'm not trying to show my nipples.
But you won't be showing it because it won't be seen.
Drop, bro, why did you do that?
To poor tempo.
Man was scoped in 499 times charge rifling.
Bro, people, your chat wants it.
They want that content.
Of course my chat wants it.
They see me as a piece of meat.
I bend over to turn my Christmas tree on and it's just non-stop fucking comments.
Wait, is that why you have a Christmas tree on?
So you can make an excuse to bend over?
No, I should get a whiteboard though.
Oh, you should.
I'm going to go down for scrims.
So every time you're like, Oh, this team won, you can bend over.
You can turn around, bend over, Oh, look at these winners!
Look at all these scrim winners.
That's content right there.
It is 100% content.
I'm asking Drop how bad your reaction time was.
Yo, the game doesn't count, okay?
Because Anonymous Zone was supposed to happen but it didn't.
So the whole game is...
Oh my god, yes.
The wipe thingy.
Wait, tell them right now.
If Prolly can do that, we can too.
Since it's your tournament, this game doesn't count.
Because anonymous mode was not on.
Yeah.
Wait, tell them that right now.
Alrighty.
What am I telling them?
Tell them that because anonymous mode was not on when you told them.
It doesn't count.
This game is wiped off.
For sure.
I think they're totally gonna listen to me after they've paid for everyone to be there for a certain amount of hours.
No, I'll just... I mean, obviously, I think Doki's right.
I'll just put another... I'll put like $20,000 of my own money into this.
Exactly.
Yeah, exactly.
And then you can make it back by having a whiteboard.
All you need to do is run one ad.
You're a genius.
Yeah, you can make it... One ad and you break even.
Exactly.
One ad, $20,000.
One ad.
You're like, maybe two ads.
New legends.
Maybe two ads.
Ash boys.
Oh yeah.
I'm going to... Top Finder CryptoVantage Caustic Lifeline.
Obviously, Tempo's caustic.
Yes.
We're on...
Olympus.
I need a white.
All right.
I mean, to be fair, the other ones are just whatever you're comfortable with, Doki.
I'm down with anything.
Honestly.
I mean, we can do Lifeline just to crack people if Tempo dies.
Wow.
That's actually probably a good idea.
Actually, if Wig dies, because you're the...
Yeah.
You're going to be taking most of the hits.
I should probably play Path for rotational purposes.
I'll play Path for our rotations.
Zip lines and stuff.
I'll play Lifeline for the crafter.
Okay.
You cool with that?
Yeah, I'm cool with that.
All right.
Let me change my skin and badges.
We're so locked in, guys.
We're locked in.
We're going to get a beacon and turbine.
Because this map...
Wish my lifeline...
We don't have a beacon.
All right.
Okay.
Lifeline.
No, I need therapy after Tempo today.
That's my dog.
All right.
I went to therapy once.
I did too.
Only once?
Both of you guys should go more than once.
Because you went once.
Of course it didn't work out.
Yeah.
It was never going to work out.
You don't know that.
You need to find the right therapist.
And the issues...
are impossible.
Whoa.
What issues?
Okay.
You know what?
Tempo, trauma dump on us right now.
We're like, you are a sociopath.
What?
Wait, really?
Okay.
I was going to be like...
Holy shit.
And you were a teacher.
Around children.
You think...
Wait.
That's why I was...
Teacher thing turned me into one.
That's the way.
Children can't turn you into a sociopath.
You're...
What is the 340...
If we get contested at Turbine, we're so choked, guys.
So we'll late drop Turbine?
Because if someone tries to contest us at Turbine, it means another POI is open.
Yeah.
There's one team per POI right now.
We'll just late drop.
And if someone contests us, we'll destroy 2009 their PC.
No one's doing Turbine, I don't think.
There's no one doing Turbine.
So we're fine.
If someone swerves...
Yeah.
Guys.
Guys, we should make a team Paranoid.
Who's like the 20th team overall?
And what is it going to be like?
We'll just pretend we're going somewhere else.
Are we 20th?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I want to make a team Paranoid by saying we're landing on their POI.
So you think they're getting contested.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Leaderboard.
Who's last right now?
Who's last?
No, that's 5Head.
Because then someone will try and kill us off drop, and then everyone will think there's three teams.
But then they'll really be contesting the other team?
Yeah!
I'm big braining this right now.
Who's the 20th team and what's their POI?
I'm looking at the leaderboard.
I mean, I'm waiting for the leaderboard to get updated.
POI.
Website.
Guys, I'm going to be honest.
Can I say a statement that we might not like here?
Okay.
Wait, what is it?
I did not believe in us for Challenger Circuit at all.
And I'm going to be honest.
Oh thank god you said that.
Wait a minute.
I believe in us less.
I'm glad you said it.
Because I don't have it.
We're going to be going against...
We're against makeshift teams right now.
Okay?
When we go to Challengers, we're going to be against teams that have been playing together for a little bit.
Yeah, and I've been scrimming and everything.
But people who are playing on a touchpad that have been playing together are still not going to be able to hit anything.
So you think these people are playing on iPads in Challengers?
They're on the Switch.
They joined the Challengers.
Oh no, not that they're actually...
I think they're actually playing on a Switch.
But they might as well be playing on a Switch.
They can't hit anything.
Oh I see.
For sure.
No, no, no.
They're uploading the scores right now.
Where?
There's no way.
That's so sad.
We have four points.
We have to be last.
Don't say that.
There's like ten teams below us.
Find the scores over here.
Please select final results.
Don't say that.
There has to be a team.
They haven't uploaded the scores.
Okay, let's just look at the current last place team and say their POI.
Oh, final results.
Alright.
How the fuck Timmy is last place right now?
Yeah, we're in ninth.
We were in ninth.
No, not yet.
That's round one.
There's three teams with zero points.
It's Timmy, We The People, and Kian.
Okay.
Yeah, I can deal with that.
Alright, wait.
Where is...
Where are they landing?
I'm gonna look at where they're landing.
Timmy was landing phase.
Kian's team's really good.
I'm not trying to land on them.
Who's Kian's team?
Terminal.
Is Terminal on...
Is Terminal the third map?
Wait, what's their third map?
Is Terminal the third map, Doki?
I know.
That's the drop spot.
She's more confused than I am.
We're playing Olympics, Doki.
I was gonna say, is Terminal in Olympics?
Okay, we're landing Terminal.
We're landing at Terminal.
What if they land on Turbine now, thinking we're going Terminal?
No, they won't.
I said we're landing Terminal.
There's no way.
If they do that, we're fucked.
They're at the last place.
Oh, wait.
They have Kai.
Never mind.
I'm scared.
I'm at the last place.
We just got back.
I have no idea how they're last.
They're good.
It's not updated yet, though.
And they have a control player, too.
No, no, no.
They're staying.
They're staying Terminal.
And you die to us in Terminal Law.
Okay, I'm just...
I'm baiting him.
I'm baiting him right now.
Okay, so hopefully Sweet goes over there and kills Kai.
And then we'll get 19.
We're so close.
I'm landing on you, Wig.
Great.
Peep just PC'd.
Start the game.
No, no, no.
Sorry, buddy.
Start it.
Bro, you're such a snitch, Wig.
Wig, the vibes were all high until Tempo got his head taken off.
I rewatched.
Rewatched what?
He rewatched the fucking clip.
He reacted 20 seconds after.
Bro, what the fuck, Tempo?
He reacted It wasn't 20 seconds, okay?
It was like 10.
How does that make him better?
Hey.
10 seconds.
That is very fast.
10 seconds reaction time.
Did you have a 6 times or a 4 to 8?
I got a 6.
Yeah, 6.
It's not my fault.
It's a 6x.
Yeah.
Guys, it's not his fault, guys.
Don't worry, we'll make it back.
Alright, let's get to... let's get to 15 points.
So we need what?
11?
11.
11 is so doable, guys.
11 points?
We need a gunpoint.
Okay, we need 6 kills in 4th place.
Yeah.
We need a beacon and we need an evac tower.
I had an evac tower!
You did?
Yeah, I told you guys!
I know, but we got stuck on command, bro.
How did they get into command if we went in the middle?
Because they went frontside.
They went frontside.
Because we went through the butthole.
They might not come back next time.
Alright, we're playing there again.
Wait, we have somebody missing on the far right.
Wait, that means that I can see where in Stormpoint is.
Who said that sucks start?
I just got jury duty.
Have fun, man.
Are you supposed to go to jury duty, like, yearly?
No.
You can pretend.
You get RNG'd for jury duty.
Yeah, you get RNG'd for jury duty and then you can tell them that you're not competent enough to be in it.
Just say you're stupid and...
What if you could, like, get on a really crazy intense big case?
That would be scary.
That's why you don't take the case.
No, no, that's why you take it.
That's why you take it and then you manipulate everyone.
Here's how to get out of jury duty.
Okay, as a...
Not an American, but, like, this is how you get out of it.
Wait, wait, wait.
Pathfinder?
Yeah.
Lifeline.
Okay, what are you playing?
Plastic.
Wait.
In Canada, what?
You gotta say something.
Okay, as I was saying, like, to get out of jury duty, if it's, like, something that's, like, a really high prolific case, you can be like, I sympathize with the murderer.
And then you already have, like, a bias towards the...
And then they're like, oh, I guess we can't have you.
Yeah, cause you have to be in jury duty, you have to have no biases.
At all.
So you can just be like, I don't know, I think he could be a...
I think he was a nice guy.
I think he's a nice guy.
So you get out of jury duty!
Cause you're supposed to have...
Why don't you just say that to the victims instead?
Like, I sympathize with them.
Well, you don't say it to the victims, you say it to the judge, cause they're picking the people who are doing jury duty.
No, you're not even...
Yeah, so they won't know you said that, you know?
Only the victims will know.
True.
Only the judge will know.
And then they'll be like, we can't put you in jury duty because you already have a bias towards the murderer.
I don't think you have to worry at all, Dokie.
I don't think you're ever getting picked based off these statements you said.
Never.
They're watching.
They're watching you now.
Take this seriously and show us OG wig?
What do you mean take this seriously?
That is a joke, guys.
This is a joke.
It's not a joke.
Get her.
It's a joke.
It was a joke, guys.
For legal reasons, this is a joke.
No.
For legal reasons, she's being serious.
Take this seriously.
Do not take my advice.
Minus tempo on Caustic.
Wait, we don't have a beacon again.
I'm gonna fucking cry.
Again?
I might cry.
Just jump right now before someone just jumps.
Before somebody tries to take Why am I jumping?
Before somebody takes Turbine from us.
Yeah, please.
We need something in this world.
Yeah.
How do we not have a fucking beacon again?
This game actually wants me to go last.
Guys, I don't want this.
I don't want to be bottom five, guys.
What did you just say?
No, that's for sale.
No, that shit is gone.
What are you talking about?
We are bottom five for sure.
No.
What happened?
We used to be so good at this game.
We were supposed to do Challenger Circuit.
You are still doing it.
Yes.
I don't know.
I don't have high hopes anymore.
I never had high hopes to begin with.
I can't believe you said that actually.
I'm low key impressed that you said that.
Hey, Tempo.
Please.
Just do that.
I pinged it too.
Oh my god.
Wait.
I have the perfect excuse.
I'm categorized as platformer.
You guys should have been carrying me.
Of course.
This is so embarrassing.
Tempo, based on this zone.
I mean, no offense.
Where do you think this is going?
He should know because he watches so many scrims.
Yeah, Wig.
You should know because you watch so many scrims.
Both of you guys should know.
That's what I'm saying.
Why just me?
That's true, actually.
I want to go into Energy Depot.
But there's a team there.
We should just keep walking up towards this.
I'm following Wig.
You make the yellow dots and I just follow.
Okay.
Let's start moving.
I have no idea where the zones are going.
God.
Now I know why no one picked Turbine.
This loot sucks.
Honestly, my loot is pretty good.
We got scammed by a social beacon.
Oh, they're far.
I lose pretty dog shit.
I have no attachments on anything or bats.
I'm going to get a bat right now, though.
I'm not great.
I'll be honest.
So you lied.
I'm not bad.
You literally said your loot was pretty good.
Did I say I was good?
You said your loot was pretty good.
Let's go Energy Depot.
Let's go this way.
We're going to move up.
Oh my god.
I fucking need that.
Fuck me.
Just pick it up.
Pick it up.
Just go up there.
Tempo, you go up there first.
And just watch out.
Wait, they're fighting behind us.
Come back here.
Get in front of me.
Okay.
Come on.
Where?
Go back up.
Okay.
I'm turning around.
We got a point.
It's time to leave.
We're not last.
We should leave.
We shouldn't be there.
Go back down.
Yeah.
Wait for my zipline.
We're going to go across the small building over here.
Come here.
Take this.
We're not going to die.
Okay.
I didn't hesitate.
I didn't hesitate this time.
Good.
Nice.
We're valid.
See, we're good.
We're going to play here.
We're going to play here for right now.
Don't stand on the roof.
Tempo.
No roof action.
There's a 4x.
Oh, wait.
I need that actually.
He's a 2x4 for me.
Well, wait.
This is nice.
I'm dropping a 2x.
Okay.
I don't need it.
We're good.
There are a lot of people rotating in over here.
I don't know where this is going.
42 damage and a kill.
Guys, we're not last.
We're 19th last.
We're at like one point right now.
Tempo, this is going to be for you.
Okay.
We need you to get us blue armor.
Why is no one getting this care package?
Did you scan the care package already?
I did.
Yeah.
They got it.
We're doing it.
I'm so proud of all of us.
Oh my god.
Here you go.
You don't need a heal, Tempo.
I will give you one little heal.
Yeah.
Great job.
Good job.
We're not wasting meds.
Alright.
We're good.
We'll make a play.
I heard a Crypto.
They're over here.
There's a lot of people rotating towards us.
That's why I'm confusing where the zone is going.
I'm scared.
What if they come to us from behind?
No.
We're fine.
I want to put some traps out here, buddy.
Maybe a little bit farther up.
So we know they walk up on us.
Yeah.
Exactly.
Oh my god.
We're so smart.
You're getting it.
You're understanding.
We're getting there.
We're figuring this out.
I don't see anybody yet.
I hope they kill more people.
So we can be like 18th place.
We shouldn't be on the roof.
It sounds so much better than 20th.
It's insane.
Yeah.
I know.
For some reason, 18th place sounds like a lot better than me in 20th place.
It sounds fantastic.
I'll take 18th place all day.
I know.
I'm not using this two times if no one wants it.
I have a 2x4.
I don't need it.
Okay.
My bad.
I'm so sorry.
I don't know where to go.
We're good.
We just wait.
We have a re-deploy.
I have a Moby.
We don't have a re-deploy.
I do have a zipline.
Efficiency.
We can make this work.
18th place.
Let's go.
I'm saying if it goes towards the garden, our rotation is not that bad.
There's still a guy here.
Oh, I see him.
Green Pathfinder.
Okay.
Someone type in this chat right now to not push us.
It's so real for that.
Max, stay still.
We have some collision going, so I never...
There's no rules in Twitch Rivals about colluding.
They never said no colluding.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's see how bad my zone call was, yeah?
We got scanned.
We got surveyed over here.
I don't know.
Feel free to roast, though.
Let's see how it goes.
Guys, for legal reasons, that's a joke, guys.
Do not go to the chat.
Because I think he'll actually push us now that he knows we're there.
Alright, we gotta go Rift.
We gotta go Rift.
Come, come, come, come.
And then just a whole team just flew in.
We're so chocked.
Oh, no.
A whole team just flew in this building.
And this building passed.
I wanna go next if we can.
I'm gonna push that one down.
Come here, come here.
Okay.
Oh, there's a team here.
Fuck me.
Go back, go back, go back.
We can't go this way.
We literally can't go this way.
I have a...
I'm gonna drop down my lifeline package.
Maybe we'll get something here.
Okay, you guys stay here.
Yeah, yeah.
You guys are gonna get loot.
Get EvoCache for yourselves.
Yeah.
I'm gonna go check up on Energy Depot until we can rotate.
Just stay down here.
One second.
I'm gonna skip out the scenes.
There was no EvoCache, by the way.
It was just...
Was there an evac tower on that or no?
Nope.
There was nothing.
There was a purple heavy mag.
Yay!
Wait, they're still behind us!
Wait, where are you?
Where are you?
Where are you guys?
Come over here.
Tembo, keep running.
Keep running.
We'll go over here.
Everybody, keep running.
No!
Why me?!
Why is it me?!
I'm dead too.
It's time to go.
Run, run, run.
You can craft this.
You can craft this!
This is exactly why I went lifeline.
This is exactly why How does that happen?
How do we get walked up on?
I'm getting shat on?!
I'm dead.
Bro!
What the fuck is this, man?!
Bro, when are we gonna get a fucking evac?!
We haven't got one evac!
And we haven't got a fucking beacon!
Wait, wait, we got a kill though.
So it's not a zero.
We got one point.
We got one kill.
Not a single evac.
Not a single beacon.
I'm going to lose it.
I literally did not hear anything for the team that walked up on us, to be fair.
To be fair.
Cause that's not even the team that killed you guys that just killed me.
It's a completely different squad.
Wait, your squad is already on red.
With 34 damage.
Bro, that was Max's team too.
I'm so sad.
How do I...
How do we not get a beacon?
How do we not get a single scan in three games out of Command Center?
Or fucking Turbine?
All I'm saying is like...
I think we need to let Tempo roam free and maybe we'll kill him.
Yeah.
I might just make you...
I might make you play a controller legend and you just literally land on a beacon somewhere.
And if you make it to us, by the time we get a zone, we're good.
We're so good.
I swear, this is like the best strat.
We let him roam free.
You literally land on one of those where you scan it across the map and you just meet up with each other.
Wait, what map is next then?
Next is going to be Geyser again.
But Geyser...
That's what I'm saying, bro.
Geyser, we should have a beacon somewhere, man.
Oh no, not even Commanders League.
I'm going to play a 90% and fuck it.
I'm losing it, I'm losing it, I'm losing it.
Bro, I just want to get into one fight, like an actual fight.
I know, I want a beacon to endgame.
This is crazy.
This is insane.
Guys, okay, okay.
Tempo, I believe in you to be free.
Be free, Tempo.
I can't believe it.
I actually... I can't believe we got walked up on and Tempo, I didn't even hear anything.
We didn't hear the walk up at all.
I have no idea how it's possible, dude.
Release him from his shackles.
Why is that team walking up on us?
It was Mac's team.
I fucking knew he was going to kill us.
Different fucking team.
It was two teams that pursued our building.
Oh my god.
That is insane.
Now I understand sweet dreams frustration not getting beacons.
Insane.
It's nice that you're doing a watch party in your own tournament.
I'm banning you.
Oh my god, three.
This is like your own tournament too.
Why is your own tournament so fucked up?
Why is it so cursed against you?
Why do they hate us, bro?
Why do they hate us?
That's what I'm saying.
Okay, we're back.
What do you mean we're back?
We were already back.
It can't be my own tournament and then we have a good time.
For those that know, we're going to have a good time.
It's okay.
Those teams that are winning right now, they're not having as fun as we are.
Do you think that's actually true though?
They might be winning.
Do you think that's true?
Do you believe that with your whole chest?
They might be winning, but they're not having as fun as we are.
That could be more true.
I agree.
Because somehow I'm rage induced, but I'm just having a great time.
Just remember that.
Winning isn't everything.
They might win more money and be more financially secured.
But...
What did we do?
We laughed more.
But...
But homies for life.
Actually, homies for life.
Aren't they dead?
Oh, they go to the corner.
Those teams that are doing much better than us and they are winning, you know they won't be back together after this tournament.
Also, like, they're fucking nerds a little bit.
Am I right?
Yeah, they won't.
Yeah, they're fucking nerds.
How dare they be good at a video game?
You know they won't reconvene back together and do a reunion or anything.
They're going to forget each other the next day.
Yeah.
But we won't.
We're relatable.
Chat, how did that...
Is this making you feel better, Chat?
We're like the team where it's like if we can be in a tournament, so can you.
Anything is possible for you guys.
If they are allowing us to play this tournament with all these pro players who are infinitely better than us, that means you can too one day.
Wait, wait, wait.
I'm included in that?
I don't know about infinitely better.
I won't say though.
After those shots I just gave them, they're definitely infinitely better.
I just gave them 14 warning shots.
I don't think I just gave them 14.
See, you're so relatable.
You're so relatable.
I'm just down to earth, you know what I mean?
Yeah, exactly.
You're humans.
When Chat watches other pro players, they're like, oh my god, these shots are inhumane.
That's what I'm saying.
There's no way he's able to...
But then when they watch you, they're like, oh yeah, he's definitely a real person.
That can be fun.
He's definitely a player from Apex Legends.
I shit just like you guys.
Yeah, and people will be like, oh my god, he's on controller and still missing?
So relatable.
I have a secret plan.
What's your secret plan?
There's two teams contesting at Harvester.
So?
What does that mean for us?
We're literally on Geyser.
I'm a third king of Harvester.
I'm Geyser.
We're not bad.
You know exactly what...
You know exactly what that means.
What the fuck does that mean?
We need some KP.
There's no way we're gonna be able to get there from Geyser.
We're both getting shot at.
Okay, is Temple gonna...
Temple, you can third party them for us.
I'm going Geyser for sure.
Wait, wait, wait.
Great idea, guys.
Wait.
You two land Geyser and loot.
I'll land Harvester and try to sneak like a free kill or two.
And then I'll run away.
And then I'll loot No Name.
And then I'll meet up with you guys at Geyser.
If he fails, we have...
We can craft him at Geyser.
Yeah, we can craft him at Geyser.
That is so smart.
That looks like us out there.
That was crazy.
I was thinking it was Strat.
No, I had...
I had max POV there.
Okay.
Okay, yeah.
I mean, we are sending Temple out to roam.
So, Temple, you're gonna land on Harvester.
Oh, my game crashed.
Wait, it didn't crash.
My Discord reset itself, but I'm okay now.
Yeah.
We have a plan.
We have guaranteed one kill plan.
We're just gonna let Temple roam free around the map.
I'm gonna go third Harvester.
And then Suicide.
And then you guys craft me at Geyser.
And then bring me back to life.
Yeah, that's the best plan you've ever had.
Should guarantee us one kill.
Yeah.
And then we're back in the game.
I don't know about back in the game, but yeah.
Back in the game.
See, now I'm kinda happy we didn't play this zone again.
You know what I mean?
I think you're just coping.
Nah, never.
Nah, this makes sense.
Playing this zone has been way too difficult.
I'm not kidding.
I actually went 0 for 7 on Sentinel shots to cover for you guys.
I said I'm covering for you guys and I did not cover once.
I'm covering.
We ran up.
We died.
That's why we're so relatable.
Thank you.
People watch us for the relatability.
Yeah.
People don't wanna watch a robot.
They wanna watch somebody that can make mistakes.
Yeah.
They wanna just feel like...
Is it a mistake?
Do you make mistakes?
Despite how many they make.
Look, I'm saying as a team.
As a team.
I'm not singling out...
I'm not singling out anybody here.
But if anyone wants to give out examples of how they made mistakes, that's on them.
For sure.
I can't think of a mistake for my end.
But like...
Oh no, never.
We never know.
That's cause you don't make them.
If anybody else wants to tell what mistakes they made, that's totally fine.
Tempo, if you wanna open up bro, we're not gonna try.
Yeah, you wanna open up too Tempo.
Zero mistakes.
Oh, zero mistakes.
Oh, okay.
Then we know.
Zero is a little delusional.
Just a little.
I like how when I was like, I don't remember my mistakes.
You're like, yeah, you're right.
And then for Tempo it's like, oh, you're delusional.
I don't remember what happened.
Why can't you put that down?
It went out the window.
Double Moby is crazy and we can't even find an Evac fucking tower.
We can't even find...
There was no fucking anything in my package.
I got a purple Evac.
That was great.
And they got double Moby.
And we can't find a fucking Evac.
Unreal.
Okay.
All our luck.
I think it's because you're the tournament organizer.
Every fucking luck is not with us.
That's low key true though.
I feel like I actually cursed myself by being the organizer.
What?
You should...
Okay, you know what would have been funny?
Honestly, Greek should have been a caster in your tournament.
Honestly, they asked me if I wanted to play or cast.
I don't think I regret my decision yet.
I feel like it would have been so funny that Greek would have casted you in your own tournament.
In my own?
That would be so fucked.
Just make him watch.
Yeah, just make him do a watch party.
That would be so fucked.
Wait, whose team is this?
Oh my god.
You still casted Dvar.
Hey, wait a minute.
How come I can't...
Can't what?
It's anonymous mode.
They did trust us.
It's been on this entire game.
What do you mean?
I didn't notice.
And a self-revive on Lifeline is crazy.
That boy Janja will win.
I'm kind of happy about that to be honest.
You know what?
We know the plan, right?
Don't let him land on Harvester.
You can just craft me.
We can craft him.
I'm down.
It's the smartest thing we can ever do.
That's like guarantee one point.
Make sure you know they're going there though.
I just need a fuse.
No, he analyzed the situation.
He analyzed the situation.
Yeah.
He looked at all the drop spots.
Yeah, he made a spreadsheet and everything.
How many games is this?
Is this like six games or five games?
Three more to get.
Okay, six games.
This plan should work.
Three more to get.
Oh boy.
25 points.
So we need eight a game.
Wait, Jen is going...
Harvester.
Wait, he's going Harvester.
I think that's one of the teams.
Someone else is going Harvester.
Janja and...
Janja and who?
Who's Jen?
We're two Harvesters here.
Who's the two Harvester team?
Oh yeah, Janja and Jen.
Oh shit, I'm going to be like, we're landing Harvester too.
No, no, no.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay, okay.
Wait, I need to wait for the legends.
I need to be able to throw like a million nades at them.
And just run away.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
A million nades, one or two kills, and then run away.
A million nades.
You're so confident in games now.
No, you need to die.
No, I'm going to...
If you die by the time we're leaving Geyser, then we can't craft you.
I'm going to loot No Name.
I'll kill them and then...
Oh wait.
I'll kill all of them and then just loot all of Harvester myself.
Exactly, you go in there and just guarantee a kill.
It doesn't matter.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm catching...
Fusey.
What are they saying in the chat, bro?
There's no Fuse.
Pathfinder, Octane, Bloodhound, Rampart, Catalyst.
Alright, so obviously I'm playing...
I guess I'll play either Globa or Newcastle.
Which one should I do?
I feel like we're always poor on loot.
I feel like...
Yeah, yeah, we definitely are.
I feel like we have been doing really well in the loot department.
Just saying.
Yeah, I mean, what dickhead put us on this planet?
Oh wait, this is the one game that doesn't have an assault.
No.
It's fine, it's fine.
It's fine, you don't need it.
All you need to do is just kill them.
That's really it.
If you're dropping over there, we need the ring.
So we're gonna have to wait for you to craft the ring.
I'll just kill all of them and then do the ring at Harvester.
You're so optimistic, I hate it.
Okay, let's do it, yeah.
Okay, I'm down.
This is what our brain is telling us.
We need a rover to listen to our brain.
Yeah, Rampart or Catalyst then.
Well, that's on you guys.
I'm good with my choices.
Who are you going for?
Left, and then...
Who are you playing, Doki?
I'm playing Loba for the loot.
Because we're always poor.
Yeah, yeah, I'm gonna play Octane.
We're always broke.
We're always broke?
What do you mean?
We're so broke all the time.
Alright, I'm gonna go Octane.
This is it.
This time.
No, I actually think this is the one.
I'm not kidding.
No, this is the one.
100%, dude.
Since you're the headliner, right?
Can you make them make up an award for us?
Like, the most...
the happiest team?
The happiest team?
I feel like it would be first.
Gotta be a little bit happier than first, right?
Okay.
I'm not saying my happiness levels are down, but you know what I mean?
The most fun team.
That one we take.
The teams with the best vibes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Tell them...
Tell the Twitch Rivals staff to pick...
The Golden Cockies!
Yeah!
They should nominate us!
The Golden Cockies?
What is that?
What is it called?
The Golden Pants?
The Pants!
What is it called?
Cackies?
Cackies!
Yes!
Is that not how you pronounce it?
The Golden Cockies?
They had to nominate us for the Golden Cackies!
And then we win by sheer...
popular vote!
Unless Hal is in there, so obviously we're not gonna win.
No, no, no.
Your VTuber army wins.
No, no.
I think...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't know about that.
Is that time?
Yeah, there's time.
Okay, I'm going, I'm going, I'm going.
Okay.
Who is everyone running... oh.
It's okay.
They're not gonna start the game.
We're so fine.
Yep.
Oh my gosh.
Alright, alright.
So the plan, Tempo.
You...
Harvester.
You die.
I wish I had a fuse, but...
Wait, what are you playing in?
Cat.
But if I get a kill and I can run, I'm gonna run through NoName and then meet up with you guys to wherever you run.
No one's looting NoName.
Okay, but like...
How do I land in Harvester to grief?
Yeah, I was gonna say, how are you gonna...
How are you gonna get to us?
Y'all can just punch some... oh, no, wait.
No, I can't.
You're gonna punch... don't punch someone!
I was gonna say, punch them into the lava and then block them with Rampart...
Punch them into the lava and then block them with Rampart walls.
Bro, just...
Don't... don't...
Tempo, your only job.
Do what you can to get a kill.
Do not trip.
That is your only mission.
That's really it.
I believe in you, Tempo.
I can't believe our first team was our peak.
I can get two kills.
Greek isn't last with us.
Wait, we're last, too?
Wait, that's...
No, that's good, though.
That's good.
Wait, the score... wait, Greek?
Wait...
Who's Greek on...
Wait, we have five points.
Yes!
So he's guaranteed last.
Oh, my God, it's the best M.O.I.
Oh, my God, it's amazing.
Wait, who's Greek with?
Timmy?
Reptar.
Reptar and...
Didn't Reptar pick first?
Yeah.
Doki just exploded.
Wait, what about landing tunnel that's close to the balloon?
What's the tunnel that's close to the balloon?
In Harvester.
Are you picked first, though?
It's the curse.
I can feel the curse.
There's a tunnel?
Oh, it started.
You guys have your picks?
I have my pick.
Wig?
I bet you Wig ran into Greek.
Wig, we can't have minus five.
We only have five points.
Who am I playing?
I thought you were playing Octane.
Yeah, I'm playing Loba.
Yeah, I got cat.
I was gonna say, we literally only have five points.
We can't have a minus five.
I mean, even if we got ten points here, we're still bottom five.
Wait, what?
Where are you seeing the scores?
The Google Sheet thing isn't updated.
I'm just guessing.
Bro, what?
Bro, what happened to us?
We fell off, man.
What do you mean?
We did so well.
We did so well last Rivals.
What happened to us?
Watch this redemption round.
Temple's gonna kill it right here.
Just remember to solo.
Wait, is that the thingy?
Oh, it is.
No minus five.
Jesus Christ.
There's the zero points.
Holy fuck, dude.
Oh my god.
Goodbye, Temple.
Goodbye.
Pathfinder's choice chat.
We're good.
Yo, they see one random person just flying.
Yo, there's a contest here.
Oh my god, they're landing on each other.
I'm gonna go left here.
They're landing on each other.
Temple, I am waiting for that.
There's no fucking scans on us anyway, so we're fine.
Wait, what?
No, I'm okay.
I'm alive.
There's someone landing inside the no-name.
Okay, okay.
You scared the shit out of me there.
That scared the shit out of me too.
Wait, they're not fighting?
They're not fighting?
How about you need to die?
You guys have beacon over there?
No, of course not.
No, we need you to die, brother.
We were solely dependent on you dying here.
Yo, I got his beacon.
I'm running back to you.
You got his beacon?
I'm stealing their loot and I'm running with their beacon.
I thought they were contesting.
What happened?
They are.
They're contesting very far away.
Oh, okay.
Very far away.
It's okay.
I got a beacon.
We can get a god spawn here, guys.
Oh, we're zoned?
We're zoned?
Yeah, we have zoned.
We have zoned on us.
How do you know?
I'm running.
Look at the zone.
It's going to pull up towards Overlook side.
We got a scan?
Now they're going to think we're a duo.
Oh, no.
They're actually going to run up on us.
Oh, my God.
They're going to send us.
I will bet my entire life they'll send us.
Our whole plan was for Tempo to die, but yet he's still alive.
I'm still fucking alive, man.
I left this house for you except for the helmet.
It's fine.
I'm more focused on these guys actually coming to kill us.
In the end...
In the end, what if Tempo is the one that crafts us in the end?
That would actually be so...
That would actually be poetic.
That would be so sad.
I got a W.
Oh, I have a Havoc Turbo.
Now we won.
I have a R9 Bolt.
I'm only short range.
I'm going to craft a...
Alright, Tempo, are you okay?
I'm going to craft a bat.
You're going to eat.
I'm going to eat.
Okay, I'm going to craft a bat, then.
I'm making sure I'm not getting sent down.
We're okay right now.
We're good.
Alright, we need to get this down, Tempo.
So get over here quick, and we're going to go.
Yeah, I'm here now.
We're going to get inside Overlook somewhere.
I just don't know where this zone is exactly ending.
That's my evac.
I have an increased range for my ult.
I can ult whenever, but I'll wait a little bit.
I'm evac-ing to you.
Are we staying here?
No, we're going, we're going.
Okay, I'm coming over here.
Up towards Overlook, for sure.
That's where it's gonna end.
Any of that fucking shit up top, any of those houses up top, bro, we are vibing.
Like, we're actually chilling.
We can get routed on here pretty hard, so we gotta watch out, we have no scans.
And teams are gonna have Bloodhound.
So let me go first, and whatever happens, just run away and craft me.
Alright, I'm giving you the lead here.
I'm not kidding, at any moment, if you think we're losing this gunfight, you guys won.
What if that's every moment?
Who looted inside here?
I did, I did, I did.
I have an extra battle style, you guys are far.
Okay, I was gonna say, I can loot the vault right now.
Oh, loot the vault, loot the vault, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm gonna loot the vault.
Yeah, do it, do it, do it.
I'm watching this thingy.
I need to close my blinds, I actually can't see.
Yeah, I was gonna say, where the fuck did you go?
We're good, we're good, we're good.
Alright.
Let's see, I'm gonna grab...
I'm gonna grab the knockback shield, yeah.
Knockback shield, never heard of that, let's do it.
Knockdown, knockdown.
I got the knockdown shield, guys.
If you guys get down, I have gold.
If you get knocked, just get back up.
Yeah, it's a knockback.
Yup, yup, yup.
Alright, keep on moving, keep on moving, we're good.
I'm right behind you.
We're doing great, guys, seriously.
Not last, 19th place.
Each placement is an improvement.
Wait, wait, don't come over here, wait, wait.
Okay, okay, come, come, come, we're good.
Okay.
I'm putting all my trust in you.
I shouldn't, but like...
Don't do that, please.
Don't worry, I'm gonna give you more pressure.
Give me comms real quick, one sec.
Can't tell if there's someone here or not.
I cannot, dude.
I don't think so, I don't think so.
I'm gonna go on high, I'm gonna go on high.
Okay, I got scanned.
Yeah, we're good.
I'm gonna hit beacon here, too.
We're gonna play back here and hit the beacon late, okay?
Okay.
I'm always right here.
Tempo, you have anything you shoot this guy with?
Yeah, can we climb up there?
No, we can't.
We can, like, be on the ledge here.
I think I can give you guys a zipline, though, if you need it.
Yeah, we need a zipline here.
You guys can get over here to zipline.
I wanna put it down below, like...
Alright, yeah, yeah, yeah, we're here.
Yeah, come over, I'll have 20% on it.
Just stay up here for now.
Did you put cat cues over here, Tempo, at all?
Uh, yeah.
I threw one up over there.
Yeah, we're gonna do that for right now.
Okay.
This is rampart, so teams are definitely gonna think it's enemy here, for sure.
I have only short range.
Okay, I have long range, I'm good.
I have flat.
I ping the longbow and stuff.
Yeah.
Good.
I already have one, I'm sure.
Yeah, yeah, but for tempo, I meant.
Let me check if there's any sniper.
Oh, there's sniper ammo here if you need it.
Oh, I might be able to...
I'll take afterwards, yeah.
I'm just gonna play on this side to make sure no one pushes us.
Are you fucking poking them with a fucking...
One sec.
I'll do this for you guys.
You guys stay there, okay?
Okay.
I'm gonna do this for y'all, just in case you wanna come up here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I wanna be free.
And I'll play the other side, though.
You can go from there.
I'll be here.
Yeah, you're good.
Nice.
They're fighting over here.
They're fighting.
How hard?
Hard fighting.
They just inted each other.
They kill each other?
They kill each other, yeah.
I don't think there was a way for us to get there.
Yeah.
I'm gonna put a low ball right here, so see if there's a sniper.
Go for it.
I'm gonna hit the beacon when it's closest.
I have my zone thing now.
All right.
So we're good to go.
Pew.
Oh, there's snipers for you.
There's snipers.
154.
Okay.
And there's sniper scopes.
There's sniper scopes.
You can do this.
I hit the...
I did my upgrade.
I'm on perk.
Someone...
Someone get the stuff before it's gone.
I'm going now.
Before someone shoots it.
Look at the zone.
We need to move up.
Okay.
All right.
We need to take more space in zone.
We have a good...
We need to get this house right here, okay?
All right.
I'm heading over to you.
Yeah, you're good.
We get in here, we're vibing.
Make sure we...
Okay.
Now, when we're in this house, we 100% can get sent on.
Just play slow.
All right.
My Q takes someone behind us.
Yeah, there's people behind me.
There's people behind me.
Can you cover me?
Yeah, you're good.
I'm looking for you.
We're vibing.
That's all right, I don't wanna dive through the window.
I'm here.
You're good.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
We're vibing.
I'm vibing.
I could have Q'd, but I didn't because I had more confidence in you guys as a team.
Thank you.
We're good.
Had a lot of confidence in all of you to protect me so I never Q'd.
I would definitely Q.
Me and Tebow are not good.
That means I trust my homies.
Get your homies.
Thank you so much.
My life is in your hands.
That's too much.
No pressure.
I don't even know where I got shot at.
We can get farmer guys here.
Oh, right here.
On Crafter.
Okay.
But the zone's actually not bad for us.
We're fine right now.
We're doing pretty good.
Is anyone in Big House over here at Tempo?
Do you know?
I'm gonna check.
You guys stay there.
Whoa.
Now I see it.
Now I know what you guys are talking about.
No one's in here.
I mean, they might be routing it, but I think they sent it.
I'm gonna go in here once.
I just wait.
Okay.
We can't craft you if you die.
I know.
You're good.
There's no one in here.
Come with me.
Okay.
Actually, you might need to node that, Tempo.
Yeah.
Node what?
Just scan me.
Woo.
Am I...
It's that...
Oh, it's...
I'm dead.
I'm dead!
How did she do this?
Not a camera for you, Tempo.
How did she?
I'm good.
I'm okay.
How does she fucking do it?
I'm losing so many cells.
It's crazy.
I'm just gonna not peek anymore.
I'm good.
We're good, guys.
We're all good.
I don't know how the fuck we did it in here, but we did it, guys.
I don't know how I lived that, but let's go.
Joe, I'm very proud of you.
Good shit, guys.
Okay.
Are you getting sent on?
Are you teaming with us now?
Underneath our house.
Underneath us, which is fine.
Okay.
I put a Loba stick on the door.
They're shooting my stick, but that's okay.
I grabbed some stuff before they could.
If you guys want more ammo, there's some here.
I'm just gonna...
Teemu, we don't have enough meds.
Don't peek too much.
You guys can grab ammo here.
Oh, there's 39 cells.
Oh my god.
I'm chillin' out.
Oh, I should've picked cells.
I'm so stupid.
Okay, we'll do the next one.
We're good.
Oh yeah, that's right.
Are you ready?
Teemu, you wanna pick?
You wanna do the thing?
Yeah, one sec.
I'm gonna heal up.
39... 33 cells is gigantic for us, guys.
Yeah, that's so nice.
Good fucking call on the Loba, dude.
I told you!
I know because we're always poor!
Every game!
We have to play Loba to have anything in life.
Wig.
What's up?
Ooh, I'll take that if you don't need it.
Yeah, I grabbed the charge rifle.
I'll put the next one here.
You need a sniper ammo, buddy?
I can give you something if you need.
I got it.
I picked it all from the thing.
Alright, big dog.
Let me know if you need more.
It's loot time.
Loot time.
My existence is to just sit here because I don't have any range.
Yeah, you're good.
Just the team underneath us.
Make sure we just don't get walked up on.
Yeah.
I'll aim up this window at them.
Wait.
They're on our roof now.
I think they're on our... Oh, they're on our roof.
Okay, I was gonna say, I feel like they might rampart our door.
Honestly, them being on the roof is pretty good for us.
Yeah, they're like our wall.
How is this guy walking up if there's a team on our roof?
They're breaching...
As I say, they're not gonna push us and this team just literally sits there for free.
It's crazy.
They have their priorities.
Oh yeah, we're locked in.
We're so good, guys.
We got good spots.
Look at us.
Yeah, we're killing it.
We're fucking killing it.
We just need a team to die around us.
That's what I'm saying.
And we're gonna get so much loot.
We should be good for next zone.
I'm pretty sure the next zone's gonna pull towards us.
Yeah, me too.
I think.
I could be wrong.
I'm just gonna believe in you.
Thank you.
That's actually the nicest thing you're saying.
I've always believed in you.
Thank you so much.
Like, why is YBNCC with you for seven... maybe hypothetically seven hours?
Isn't this guy just out in the open?
Three and a half hours.
Probably.
He's just out in the open shooting.
I don't know how he's doing that with a team on our roof.
Isn't there a team on our roof?
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
I'm confused.
They're not looking at him.
That's how.
They might push us if they knock us, to be honest.
100%, yeah.
Okay, I'm gonna go put...
I'm a little horny.
Yeah.
How is this team on the roof not shooting these guys?
And what's this, the third on our roof?
I'm gonna grab this armor and then also these shields.
Oh my god, bro.
The cells are such a vibe.
Yeah.
It's unreal.
Such a vibe saver.
It's crazy.
Good shot.
Let us go.
They can't kill us because we always have unlimited cells.
This has to be his teammate that's on our roof.
There's no way these guys are able to peek this without getting shot.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure.
Yeah.
I mean, this guy is just in the open, in the open.
This is crazy.
If anyone was...
Who the hell would run Newcastle in this lobby?
Someone with a lot of...
Someone that's not Geyser for POI.
And someone that's very confident in their ability.
Yeah.
Oh, they took this.
1, 2, 1, RV.
Oh, nice.
Oh my god, he's flesh.
That team should die.
There's no way someone's gonna die.
Don't you let them do that.
Well, I think they're doing it right now.
They are doing it.
They're good.
They're chilling.
Guys, guys, guys.
Soon.
Holy shit.
Listen, we gotta hold it down here, guys.
We gotta hold it down.
I've never been top 10 before.
I'm the...
Don't jinx it.
Genuinely, genuinely, if we get sent on and people are trying to push in our building, we do not contest.
We back up here and throw grenades here, okay?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm being so serious.
Yeah, I'm being so serious.
I'm so for real right now.
I'm not even trying to be funny.
I opened their door.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, they might be...
Oh, wait.
Does the real...
Does Sheila break through cat door or no?
Yes.
They can.
Really?
It does.
It can.
That's why I was like, be careful of this door.
Be careful.
I heard the wide up and I'm scared now.
I heard the wide up.
The wide up is giving me fear.
I'm scared.
It is?
Oh, the big air slo.
I don't need air.
This is...
This is just...
It's just high, but I suddenly got out of control and
I was scared again.
Yeah.
Oh, this is insane.
You just became the Hippoc tops, all this stuff.
By now we're all chiefs, I think, and we've got nearly the same points.
We wanna talk to chatikto.
Okay.
Amazing.
We didn't target the...
Serious.
If we didn't...
Sendon is like literally just walk back and forth.
I have another low ball.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
That's great.
More people are going to die near us too.
This is fantastic.
I might actually just take grenades.
There's a lot for her.
I took two grenades.
I'm just going to put them on the ground.
If we need them.
Me too.
We're definitely not going to need anything else.
We should be fine.
You guys are just picking up the grenades that you threw down.
Yeah.
Why did we pick up the grenades we dropped?
I'm sick to my stomach, dude.
Fuck me, man.
Okay, that's pretty funny.
It's a Sheila.
Take the door.
Okay.
I'm going to collapse this.
I'm going to look for picks here on the back side.
I'm looking with you, just in case.
Yeah, we're vibing.
Top 12, guys.
Zone, are we in?
Alright, guys.
Don't...
We're in.
We're in this corner.
We're playing that corner.
We walk out late.
We're going to show no presence once the zone closes.
The only way they know we're here is from our low ball.
That's fine.
I need to get fucking purple, bro, for a zipline really bad.
We got to get purple here.
There's people.
There's a guy.
There's a Newcastle behind this wall.
Alright, we got scanned from below.
Come on.
There's a Newcastle right here behind this.
He's just...
I need to get purple.
Oh, he's rotating to the left.
Oh, I couldn't see him in time.
It's a little rat.
He's a little rat guy.
It's a little rat guy?
Yeah, he's a little rat.
He's ratting up there.
I have low ball in 20.
We're good.
We're doing great.
We're doing great, guys.
I need my zipline here so we take less damage on zip.
Really bad.
I need to get this purple.
Fuck me.
I missed the shot.
I need my zipline here so we take less damage on zip.
Oh my god.
Let's fucking go.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
Let's fucking go.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
I want to shoot this guy so bad.
I have low ball in 10.
Yeah, we're good.
We're good.
Just keep holding.
Literally make sure that no one pushes this door.
That's all we need right now.
Just make sure we don't get shielded in the back late.
Yeah, I'm looking.
I'm looking for you guys.
We're good.
I'm going to keep staring here too.
One sec.
I'm going to keep looking in the back.
You guys look cool.
I'm looking in the store just in case.
Yeah, you guys look cool.
I have ult here.
I'm going to put my ult right here.
I regret the decision fully.
That guy's a beast.
That zipline is so fast.
There's a red.
There's a red for us here if you need it.
Oh, nice.
You should take that.
Yeah, yeah.
Refresh.
Refresh it.
You should refresh it.
It's a refresh, not a natural red.
Yeah.
Grabbing two grenades.
Yeah, I'm going to take...
I am going to grab...
Wait, do I need batteries?
No.
I'm going to grab AA.
We're good.
We just play that corner, guys.
We're just going to play that corner.
I'm going to grab an A then too.
How in are we?
Fighting in that room.
Kind of.
Tempo, you got to stay in this corner.
Our little corner.
We're good.
We're going to zip out late game somewhere.
We have a lot of room actually.
Wait, are we going to die in here?
No, no, no.
We're good.
We're going to walk out late.
Okay.
Only one of us can peek at a time.
I'm not even kidding.
I'll peek.
Yeah, yeah.
We will peek.
He has the armor.
He's one shot.
Fuck me.
Jump again, you little bitch.
Guys, I have 56 damage.
Nice job.
I'm contributing.
Alright, what we're going to do here, guys.
Did you see this little cliff here late game?
We're going to go to this cliff here late.
Okay?
We're going to literally walk out left.
We're going to walk into the front door and we're going to go out to the left side.
Okay.
We're going to have to go pretty early though because we can't fucking get killed.
Fucking through storm.
I believe.
I'm going to need to grab this Mozambique.
Wait.
Is there a heat shield?
Because we can have that one second heat shield.
No.
They do the tournament mode.
Oh, it's tournament mode.
We got to wait six seconds.
We're going to go now.
Go now.
Go to the cliff.
Jump to the cliff.
Jump to the cliff side.
Right here.
I'm here.
Come here.
We're good.
We're going to look left.
We're going to look left immediately.
Look at these kids.
They're going to try to shoot us.
Okay.
They're going to be kids right above us too.
No, we're good.
We're good.
We're so good.
Just stare left.
Someone stare left.
I'm staring.
You're good.
We're going to walk in late.
We're just going to walk in late.
We can't really watch here.
Oh my god.
How is there six teams still alive?
At least can they move over here.
They're moving over.
The full team on my right.
On here.
Yeah.
Shoot this guy.
I'm shooting.
We're good.
Shoot left.
It's the only team that can kill us right now.
Tempo is not shooting left.
I'm watching.
No.
He's doing good.
It's fine.
Okay.
If someone walks behind us, they're idiots.
They shouldn't.
Yeah.
I'm watching behind us.
Okay.
Here.
They're looking.
On us.
Yeah.
They're looking.
No, bro.
Right when I stopped peeking.
No.
I said they're looking.
I'm going to stop looking.
Why didn't you stop looking?
I threw.
No.
Of course I threw.
And I got wounded.
The moment they stopped looking.
You stopped looking.
I sold.
I sold like a fucking car salesman.
They pushed the timing.
And now my camera fell.
Now my camera's on the floor.
My whole setup just fell.
Bro, wait.
I think today's just not your day.
Oh my god.
He died too.
Oh man.
Guys, it's okay.
We got six guys.
That's a lot of points.
A lot of points.
We got six.
We got six guys.
I trolled that, guys.
Guys, you fucking threw that, man.
I'm sick to my stomach, dude.
Okay, we're back.
I have to go pee like every 15 minutes.
Why?
That's not healthy.
That's not healthy at all.
There might be something wrong.
I had a bunch of energy drinks.
I just have to keep peeing.
What?
God.
Bro, you must be super dehydrated.
That is not healthy.
Top six?
Top six is not bad.
How did I not get one?
Top six is pretty decent.
We're at eight now.
Yay, eight points.
Yay.
We got eight points in total.
Wait, how do you wait?
You are ass.
Fandom.
Why?
What did I do to knock?
Fandom.
Do it.
No pause.
What did I do to knock, bro?
Okay.
Where's Greek?
Okay, Greek is team 14.
Team 14.
Team 14 got 19 plays with zero kills.
So, they're actually last last.
Oh, my God.
They're probably malding right now.
I'm so happy.
Bro, they're actually last last.
We're not last because we got points with placements.
That's so good for us, dude.
My camera is so fucking boxed right now.
My whole camera service is fucked.
This is crazy, dude.
Alright, new goal.
Not last.
That's my new goal.
That wasn't last.
We did it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We got it.
As long as Greek's team does not have a winning game, we're fine.
That's what I'm saying.
That's what I really care about.
Yeah.
Is that not winning?
Your roommate doesn't win at all.
Is that what you want?
I can't explain to you.
Right when I looked away, they pushed.
Yeah, I know.
I was like, where did you go?
I looked back and you were gone.
I fucked it up so bad.
I was like, where did you go?
Where did my other person go when he said this is the only angle that matters?
And then I immediately just looked at the other team.
Right when I said that.
That is insane.
I just completely blacked out because I just saw a full three man in the back.
I did like 800 damage to him too.
That was crazy.
I got too horny.
This is what it is.
Alright, Wizards top six.
Next one's top five.
Yeah?
Is that how math works?
Next one's top five?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We got this.
Okay.
Command center with Snipe's team.
Jurassic is open.
There's two teams contesting Stormcatcher.
Jurassic's terrible, bro.
So do we want Jurassic bald?
Oh my god, Jurassic's so bad.
Isn't Jurassic way worse loot than anywhere else we can go?
But on this map that I googled, it has a beacon.
That means we get a beacon.
We're not contesting that Jurassic if we go there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Because somehow we still didn't have a beacon at Geyser.
Let's do it.
Let's just go Jurassic.
Alright.
If we go Jurassic and there's a beacon at command center?
Well, no.
There's a team command center too.
Yeah, yeah, that's fair.
Okay, let's go Jurassic.
No, no, no, no.
This is it.
Wait, wait.
What?
What happened?
I was going to do the same thing.
Can we?
Is there a crafter at Jurassic?
I mean, Temple, we got nothing out of you doing that.
Yeah, we got beacon.
I scanned Harvester's beacon when I ran back.
But if we have beacon here, we don't need it.
So let's see first.
Alright, alright.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And if not, I'll go third Stormcatcher, scan beacon, and then die.
Oh, yeah, yeah, because we have crafter.
We have crafter.
Yeah, and two teams are contesting as Stormcatcher.
So we're good.
It's the exact same plan.
Yep.
This is it.
Okay, wait.
Okay, so what are the legends?
What are the legends that's our...
Because, like, our strategy also relies on what legends we can play too.
We're all locked in.
No, I think, like, letting Tempo be free actually made our gameplay so much better.
I think so too.
Yeah.
We don't have to worry about him.
Yeah, we don't have to worry about him.
We just have to let him... we just have to free him.
Then roam around.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Then do what he wants to do.
Oh, man.
It's okay, guys.
We're not last.
We are.
Okay, so Tempo Travels is raiding and also just giving 25 subs to whoever...
a random streamer that's involved.
That's pretty cool.
Oh!
Ballistic Wraith Rev Valk Cat Mirage.
Okay, so clearly Wig should play Valk.
Oh, no, wait.
There's a Fuse in there too.
Clearly Wig!
I think a unanimous decision for the squad is that Tempo's not on Valk.
Yes.
The moment Tempo was on Valk, we got 20th!
You're so right.
Okay, and then Tempo will play Calus, right?
And then I'll be Mirage for the crafting.
I think...
You're playing Mirage?
For sure.
We need the crafting.
Where should I play?
No!
Are you comfortable on Mirage?
Oh, yeah.
I'm very comfortable on Mirage.
Why are you so comfortable?
I do not believe her.
Why do I not trust what she's saying?
I'm so comfortable.
Oh, yeah.
I'm comfortable.
I'm so comfortable on Mirage.
Don't worry.
When you see my banner, you'll understand.
It also has zero kills?
No!
No, no, no!
No, no, no, no, no!
Look at my Season 5 win!
I'm so comfortable on Mirage when it was Season 5.
When it was Season...
Okay.
Season 5?
Season 21?
Check my Mirage.
Yep.
Check it.
I'll check it when we go in there.
I'm actually so mad at myself, it's unbelievable that I looked at my Mirage.
Okay.
What is wrong with me?
What am I doing?
I can't blame Tempo.
Yeah, I can't blame him.
You can't blame him.
Yeah, me looking away.
I fucked up, you know what I mean?
I got too horny.
I just got way too horny for the squad.
I saw...
What?
What the fuck?
You're like...
Your mic.
What the fuck?
Oh no, it's all going downhill.
It's all going downhill.
Oh my god.
I still don't know why Nob called me ass.
Did you check my Mirage stats?
No, are you live right now?
No, just press F.
What?
I've never seen that before.
Oh my god.
You have 3600 kills?
I do have so many Mirages.
Look at my wins.
Wait, what's Mirage's thing?
I can't believe you played that character that much.
Only in Season 5.
And then I never touched Mirage again.
I was on the Mirage leader points for Season 5.
Oh my god.
I was!
I was like top 10 Mirage players because of my Mirage wins.
I was like number 1 in Canada.
Because I had the most Mirage wins in Season 5.
Who the fuck are you?
Why are you in Canada in Season 5?
Because I had the most Mirage wins.
It's legit!
I remember because I thought it was so funny when I looked at the leaderboards.
You being top in Mirage wins is pretty fucking funny to me.
I'm expecting a carry.
A Mirage carry.
In Canada.
The score is updated.
I'll be right back real quick.
It's not updated.
That's right.
Number 1 in Canada.
That's all that matters.
I was top 10 in the world for Mirage wins.
We're in 18th.
Guys!
We're doing it!
Alright.
We need to get to top 10.
Okay?
I just want...
If we get 17th or 16th I'd be happy.
That's really it.
No.
We need to get around top 10.
This is sort of telling me how it's going to be.
in CC right now.
I'm sort of having a feeling where we're at at CC.
CC will be much easier.
I'm back.
How we looking?
CC people actually scrim!
CC will be easier.
People in CC actually scrim!
No.
I think Temple's right.
They shoot like they're not playing with a mouse.
Yeah.
Like Doki.
You're going to tap strafe on kids.
It's going to be crazy.
I'm going to tap strafe on kids.
I'm going to put them in a daycare and do a super glide.
On the play sets.
Oh my god.
In challenge circuit even I should be able to 1v3 some teams.
You know what I'm saying?
That's the vibes I have.
Do I have the confidence to do so?
No.
Yes.
This is our warm up.
This is it.
If there's no beacon, I'm going to go third Stormcatcher.
Steal their beacon.
For some reason this is an unbelievable strat we're doing and it's working.
We just got top 6 with you landing Harvester and us landing Geyser.
I'm not really sure I've ever seen that strat before in any level of Apex Legends.
My mom's calling me.
One second.
Yeah.
What's up mom?
Hey mom.
Hi mom.
Doki says hi.
What'd you say?
Hey mom.
You think I'm better than your son?
Doki wonders if you think she's better than me at Apex.
I don't know.
Bro she doesn't even Bro she doesn't even feel like...
...with her energy and her screaming laughing and just luck like.
She's like the best thing that ever happened.
Bro I'm the best thing that ever happened.
I hope I get to need her one day.
She's awful now now now.
Well now you have to come to land.
I'm the best thing that ever happened.
to Apex.
Alright we're in game.
I love ya.
Yup yup yup.
Bye mom I love you.
Oh my god I got the mom wig.
Wait who am I playing?
Who am I playing?
You're playing Valk.
Of course you're playing Valk.
I'm Kat.
I'm Mirage.
Where's Valk?
Valk is top right.
I knew it.
I knew I was special.
Left, right, middle.
Okay.
Alright let's lock it in.
Yo we got this.
Yeah I got this.
Tempo is not on the character that I'm on.
Which is great.
Look at it!
409 season 5 Apex wins.
Why is it gold?
Yo we have beacon and command center doesn't it?
Okay then you have to land on it with us.
We're so good.
Now you actually land with us.
Wait we can't...
We can't do the double scan thing right?
No it doesn't work.
You can scan right now and then scan afterwards too.
I mean there's no point in scanning now and after.
We just wait.
I'm just gonna land here I guess.
Sure buddy.
Wait why does that team right above us seem very close?
Wait what?
Where?
That's not my decoy by the way because I forgot to use my decoy.
Mirage player.
You should have sent it at echo and scared the shit out of them.
You should have just fucking scared somebody.
Send them all into command.
Good game last game though guys.
The Loba pick was The Loba pick was definitely the thing to do.
I agree.
Good job.
Proud of you.
Yeah.
No problem.
Oh my god.
I have my heirloom too.
Oh nice.
This is one of those heirlooms I actually paid money for.
Do you like that heirloom?
I think the Mirage statue is like one of the best heirlooms they have.
Yeah.
I love the animations on it.
I heavily relate to Mirage.
You love yourself that much?
I heavily relate to a guy that carries a statue around.
Actual goals you know.
Yeah 100%.
Tabo hit that beacon baby.
Let's see where we're going.
Don't forget I have Valkold here soon.
Did you loot this already?
I did yeah.
I'm going back then.
I'm going to hit this.
We can get a good spot.
We can get a good spot guys.
I'm going to immediately hit this god damn ulti excel and we're going to get going.
Okay guys.
Deal?
Alright I'm here.
You guys are coming back this way?
Yeah I'm going to come back to you.
There's a disruptor here with an alternator.
Oh shit.
That's probably a better one to have.
It's okay.
No big deal.
I could have got back.
It's right below you.
Oh really?
Yeah.
It's next to an alternator.
Oh shit yeah you're right.
What the fuck?
Yeah I told you.
Oh my god that's fucking coded.
Thank you.
See?
I'm a good person.
Yeah sure.
Alright I was kidding.
I'm going to have ulti here in a little bit.
We're going to probably ulti first then evac.
We want to get for this zone I think we want to get one of these two houses back here.
Oh yeah.
If it's open.
We're going to keep moving up.
We're going to go through pylon a little bit more though and we're going to back ulti right here.
Up top.
I don't know how far we can actually go though.
I'm right behind you.
I still need to see a...
Like a scope.
Wait I just see a scope.
We can grab this thing right?
Yeah we have to grab the...
We'll definitely do that.
We need that red band.
You need purple energy?
Purple yeah I do.
Nice.
You don't even have energy.
Wait I don't even see this loot.
Getting an ult decoy.
Reduce.
Oh that's a revive with health.
There's a pack on our right.
Did we want to stop for that or no?
No I think we have to get a zone.
Someone definitely landed here though.
Yeah we did.
Don't worry.
My mirage clone will distract him.
Good shit.
We're going to try to get a left side tree and ulti over.
Okay?
I keep forgetting to scan packs bro.
It's a fucking gold master.
If only we needed that shit.
Yeah it's fine.
We're going to go to tree and then ulti over.
Oh my god I have five nades.
What the fuck am I going to do with five nades?
I don't know.
Throw them?
I don't know if we have to live long enough for that.
The chances of you throwing five is pretty crazy.
Alright ready?
Oh my god we're so...
Wouldn't it be funny if you got shot?
It would be so funny.
It would be so funny if you got shot.
I feel like tempo is still running.
This could be the end of us or the start of us.
Alright we're going to try to go back side.
Just let me know if you see anyone.
We're going for this building back here.
Well there's obviously somebody there.
No I'm the building in the back.
Yep there is there is there is.
Oh there is there is there is.
We're going to go back to the terrace.
We're good we're good.
This is so easy to play.
We're chilling.
Oh you're good you're good.
I'm so good.
We're so good.
Behind us?
Yeah like driving behind and open.
I'm going to open this bin.
Let's see.
Honest question.
Giving your input.
Do you think that this tunnel is better for us or staying on staircases better?
I honestly have no idea.
It's up to you.
I think we're going to stay here to be honest.
Can I be playing tunnel without a actual good defensive character?
I have like 18 nades for some reason.
Alright.
I have like two syringes.
I haven't found single syringes anywhere.
You bitch bro.
Don't shoot me.
Wait my game lagged.
I have a glitch.
I can't heal.
I literally can't heal.
I have a glitch.
Wait what?
Every time I heal my screen goes blackouts.
Come back to me.
I just threw 18 nades at them.
Yeah you're good.
My game is fucked.
Okay so you can't do that.
My deal shows like a...
Are you cheating?
No an arm in my face.
I have a whole arm in my face.
But you still can't heal.
It's just a visual bug.
I can't see anything while I heal.
Oh okay.
My whole chat is being caught.
Oh no destroyer.
I'm cheating.
Destroyer.
Destroyer is here baby.
Destroyer don't worry.
How is our tournament?
Destroyer.
Yeah he has like so many people watching him.
Yeah.
Exactly.
Why me man?
Yeah you want publicity go for hell.
Yeah you'll get it.
Yeah you'll get all that publicity.
So many tweets.
Yeah so many engagement.
Think of the engagement destroyer.
Yeah the impressions.
Oh my god all the impressions.
I don't think I want to peek anymore guys.
I don't have a lot of heals.
Wait landing?
Tunnel tunnel tunnel.
Cracked one.
How are you guys peeking in?
Oh boy.
Where?
The right side.
Okay they're gonna be on silo.
Yeah I'm just gonna stay down here in the stairs.
I'm gonna show a little prep so we don't get sent on.
My fucking mirage clone.
Oh my god the fact that I can't see anything is crazy bro.
I have 10 cells and 2 cats.
There you go.
He's just gonna stand there and he'll let us know.
Yeah actually good comms wait.
Yeah.
He'll be like what is this mirage doing in the open?
Dude this is gonna fuck me over so hard if we actually play.
This like this is gonna be so bad.
I literally can't heal with my gun fight.
It's crazy.
Why nerf us?
Yeah why nerf us?
If you rejoin do you think that would help?
Bro if he does that he's gonna fucking we're gonna have a team push the moment he does that.
If I leave it doesn't fix anything.
I think it's just a visual bug in my game.
I just get sent on and I'm just gone.
Yeah yeah.
Shoot my clone.
He's literally having a fun time in the open.
He's real.
Imagine that's just you and they're not shooting you because they think it's a clone.
Oh my god I should.
Do you guys wanna try that?
Yeah you should do it right now.
Okay.
Okay nevermind.
Nevermind look.
I ran through it immediately.
I'm not gonna peek anymore.
I'm stupid.
I'm done.
Oh yeah I love seeing a bright yellow thing in my face.
This is fire.
Where am I?
I can't see.
The syringe is half.
My screen is covered half with the syringe.
It's ridiculous bro.
Why does no one want to shoot me?
Don't shoot her.
I don't know if that guy is actually trying to shoot my clone or not.
I saw straight bullets.
How is my clone traveling so far?
He shot him.
He got bamboozled 50 meters away.
Get on nerd.
Okay do you think this is a mirage clone?
Are they gonna shoot me?
Shoot her for the scan please.
If I die I blame Wig.
Because I'm doing something dumb.
I'm not getting shot at.
It works.
That is fucking crazy bro.
They actually let me just run around.
No way.
I peeped my head for a second and got lit the fuck up.
Alright hopefully guys a minute left we'll see the damage you're on Zelen.
I think it's going right towards us.
I don't know if they're shooting me or what they are.
Wait they are!
No!
Okay now I'm not doing that again.
We're good.
I have one shield still left because I fucked around.
Don't hit me.
Okay.
I fucked around a little so now I have one shield still left.
Nice.
How many do you have Sambo?
I have one five now.
I am two five.
Alrighty.
Let's see.
Come on baby.
Come on.
I'm real.
Chat we think if the zone comes here or what?
I don't think so.
Come on.
Yes you do.
Let's see it pull to the other side.
Come on right here.
Let's see it pull.
We're so good.
Wait.
Is anyone in armory?
We're so good.
We're going to get sent on though.
Did we just play Backside Rock over here now?
Isn't there people there?
I don't think so.
I mean we could.
It's only there for now.
We're going to hold out Southwest.
We're going to literally hold out Southwest.
That's the goal.
These guys need to die on the rotation end.
Oh I stuck my decoy in there.
I thought that was you.
Okay.
So Southwest is going to be our number one enemy here guys.
I'm going to start cleaning out soon too.
Okay.
I don't know if I want to waste some meds though.
I'm not sure if I want to waste these meds.
Yeah Tempo stop peeking I think.
Yeah definitely stop peeking Tempo.
For sure.
Don't worry I'm going to see if I can grab intel.
I'm just peeking so I can make sure these guys know that we're looking at them.
Yeah yeah yeah.
Wait are they actually sniping my decoy and missing?
I think they are.
They did.
They know we have to go this way, that's why.
They can go the other way.
Should we not go to the rock now or wait?
Nah, I think we just stay here for now.
I don't really want to jump too early and then we just get fucking shit on.
And we stop Valk ult.
Yeah, we do.
Yeah.
I just don't know if anyone's back there and we Valk ult and then they take our spot.
It's the only problem.
Yeah, that's true.
Alright, let's see where they go.
Let's keep looking over here.
Just don't take too much damage.
Someone dropped down here.
I think they're leaving us.
One other tunnel.
There's only two that left that I saw.
All three there.
Yeah, I just saw.
We're doing it.
I just got bamboozled.
Oh my god, you got bamboozled too?
Where's the care pack at?
I need to scan.
I hear a pack.
To our right.
Woah, woah, woah.
We're good.
Yeah, you want to do it?
I'll do it back, bitch.
I don't care.
That clone didn't really go anywhere.
There's a ragged team back rock.
Knock that guy.
Holy shit get shit on him.
I got shot from behind.
There's someone behind that rock.
They're behind the rock now.
Yeah, we're good.
I don't think we can kill this guy.
He's sliding down here.
Oh, nope.
He went into that tunnel.
Let's see where someone goes.
Someone just pulled back rock.
Where can we go here?
This is so bad for us actually.
Holy fuck.
Well, we can't go behind this because there's a team there now.
We can't play silo.
I don't think either.
Silo will just get shot at.
Fuck.
Yeah, they're all the way behind.
I mean, we have Velko.
We have Velko here.
We have the Helm Berry somewhere.
I think we just walk in slow and just go to silo here.
We just walk in slow and try to kill everyone that's inside.
That's all we can do.
Just play slow.
Don't take any damage.
Let these teams fight inside.
We just third party and walk up.
We're gonna play for the height.
We'll see if they fight inside.
They should.
Team flying in.
We're good.
Yep, just get some shots down.
We're all good.
Oh, they made a walk?
Yeah, they catwalked.
That's fine.
Yeah, we're good.
They're fighting whoever's there.
Yeah, just keep playing here.
Just keep playing there.
You guys be playing there.
Alright, alright.
We're looking.
One drop down, right here.
I'm looking.
Two drop down.
Two, yeah.
Yeah, just keep looking there, guys.
I'm looking at somebody else right now.
You guys keep looking there.
They're not peeking us right now.
I'm looking at you guys.
They went up.
They're going up.
Yeah, we're good.
They're on the ramp.
We need to focus these guys.
Hardcore left side.
Left side?
Yeah, I'm looking.
I got my kill.
I got Mirage.
Does anyone have light ammo?
No, I don't.
I can't spare anyone.
I do.
I'm going to use it.
Ramp.
They're shooting ramp.
Yeah, yeah.
Keep walking up slow.
We're good.
Keep shooting ramp.
Just keep shooting ramp if you can.
Shooting ramp.
Yeah, just keep looking left side.
We're good.
Just keep looking.
Nice job, Ducky.
You're doing great.
We're going to move in slowly.
Alright, we're going to walk up a little bit.
Come to me.
Take space.
Come here.
There's a team right below us.
They're going to fight each other.
That's good.
Come to me.
I'm here.
Temba, put Q's over here on the wall.
Below me.
Yeah, shoot left.
Shoot left.
Right behind us.
There's a Mirage.
Two.
Crouch.
Temba, no!
You got this, buddy.
Jump down if you need.
I'm a tree.
You're a tree.
I don't move.
Oh, it's just a duo behind us, man.
They came out of nowhere.
The Valk is right in front of me.
He doesn't see me.
Pretend you don't exist.
It's okay.
You're doing great.
Don't heal anything.
Don't do anything.
Don't shoot me, guys.
Do not do anything.
They're tunnel visioning right now.
Top 10.
Good job.
Nice.
We got top 10.
We got one kill.
Top 10.
Nice job.
God damn it.
Oh, my God.
They actually...
We got top 10.
We'll take it.
We got top 10 and a kill.
That's fine.
I got to pee again.
What?
You got what?
He has to urinate again.
What?
He has to pee again.
Temba, what the fuck is wrong with you?
I have no idea.
I don't think that's healthy.
No, it's not 100%.
That is 100% not healthy.
You're peeing like every 15 minutes.
I agree.
I agree fully.
Dude, nice job, though.
We did a good job.
Really well played.
We just killed that duo.
We could actually be alive right now, which sucks.
They just came out of nowhere.
I thought they were not rotating to us.
I don't know why they did that.
I thought they were going inside.
Same.
It worked out, but it is what it is.
Temba definitely has a bladder problem right now.
Oh, for sure.
How is he nervous?
Honestly, why the fuck is he nervous?
Yeah.
How the fuck is he nervous?
He's the diamond three in the game.
That's what I'm saying.
It's okay.
As long as...
We got top ten plus one point.
As long as Greek got not top ten plus one, I'm so happy.
Yeah, yeah.
That's all we have to worry about.
We need them.
That's all I care about.
We got the vibes.
That's all we need.
The vibes.
Wow.
Let's see this play for the Wraith.
Yeah, I'm checking the Wraith play right now.
Oh, wait.
Did he kidnap?
He tried.
No, he did.
No, he did not.
That would have been so fucking funny.
That would have been so nice if he did that.
Look at all the rats out here, man.
So many rats.
Oh, my God.
Look at all these rats.
That could have been Temba.
What?
I can't believe you got seen.
I know.
I can't believe they saw you.
You could have been free.
Yeah, I'm lowkey surprised.
Me too.
They should have been so distracted with the people above me.
Honestly, Temba, did you have cat wall there?
Yes.
We should have cat walled ourselves, to be honest.
We go to that pillar and we just cat wall off the other side.
That's my bad.
I should have told you that.
I forgot we were playing cat.
We didn't use any of our ults, except for that one bell.
Yeah, I guess.
I got shot so fast, I couldn't even ult.
No, that's not your fault.
That's my bad.
I should have told 100% Temba to cat wall us off, so teams can't push us.
Yeah, cat wall behind us.
Yeah.
Exactly.
It's okay.
The next game.
Now we know.
Three points?
Wait.
Did we get a kill?
Yeah, we got one kill.
I got to kill the Lombo.
Nice.
Yeah, yeah.
First game, Temple hasn't got a big kill for more subs.
That poor Valk.
What the fuck?
There's no way.
He tried.
That Valk definitely tried.
They did their best.
Hey, listen.
10th place, one kill.
Not awful.
Yeah, yeah.
It's pretty decent.
Pretty fucking decent, guys.
It means we're better than Greek.
Okay, let's check Greek score.
I think you just won.
Imagine.
No.
Don't say that.
Oh, no, no.
No, we needed him to not win a game.
Please, no.
Oh, no.
Okay, it's we the people.
It's not Greek.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Oh, no.
Damn it.
Wait, wait.
Where's Greek?
Greek's 14.
Where's 14?
He got zero kills.
14th place.
Zero points.
We're at six.
We're at 11.
Where's Gent?
Greek's team at zero points.
We're still fine.
Yeah, Gent's team's six.
He got ninth with two.
A little better than us.
Is he gonna pass us?
No, no.
He was already past us, but we were gonna...
Ninth with two?
Okay, so we're only three points away from Gent.
We're at 19.
It's okay.
We're not...
Greek just needs a really, really good game to...
Reptile and Greek?
Okay.
We just need to beat your roommate.
That's all I want, bro.
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
I'll be right back.
You're good.
That's all I want, bro.
That's all I need.
Okay, hopefully these next lessons are good for us.
We definitely don't need support, to be honest.
We haven't used it once, to be fair.
Yeah, I'm gonna go Fuse if she wants the controller.
Yeah, we'll see.
We'll see what happens.
I think the next one's, like, pretty weird.
I think it's, uh...
Let me see.
I know they put it there.
I think it's...
Oh, they're typing it right now.
Let's wait.
It's, like, six Skirmisher or some shit like that.
It's, like, majority of Skirmish.
I think it was.
Wait, which was Skirmisher?
Six Assault.
It's six Assault this time around?
I have no idea.
I was just making it up.
Oh.
What did Clara say?
Can y'all...
Okay, yes.
Who is it?
Assault controller support.
Okay, so we have Ash, MadMaggie, Ballistic, Watson, Rampart, Loba, Mirage, Conduit.
Holy fuck.
Um...
My god, they really saved the worst for last.
I like that.
Uh...
Alright, so who are you gonna play?
I'm Fused.
Oh, there's Fused.
Okay, good.
Who is she gonna play?
I'm back.
Wait.
Wait, what's the... what's the thing?
Mirage...
It's Ash, MadMaggie.
Oh, I can do Conduit.
Alright, I'm down.
Oh, that sounds great.
Okay, cool.
And maybe I'll just do Ash for the TP.
Yeah.
Alright, cool.
Yeah, so we got Ash...
Is Temple gonna play Watson or Rampart?
Oh, actually, yeah.
I can play Watson.
Yeah, play Watson, Temple.
Yeah, this is the last game.
As long as Grieg dies before us, then we've, like, established that we're better than Grieg's team.
Grieg, you gotta go out last, man.
No, do you know what's even...
I can't go out last.
We have no pro player on our team, but we're still above a pro player team.
Yeah, true.
If you think about it that way.
Now you're spinning.
We literally have...
Why are you a genius, Tom?
We basically won.
Any team that's below us is embarrassing.
Alright, let's pass a few more, then.
That is fucking for sure.
And it's gonna be one team, which is Grieg's.
Yeah, it's gonna be one team.
Is it funnier if it's just one team?
And, by the way, Inruptor had first pick.
Inruptor had first pick.
True.
I'm gonna be regretting that Grieg decision right now.
Alright, we'll see what happens, dude.
Alright, so I'm gonna go Ash, then you go Wattson, then you go Konduit.
Yeah, yeah, I go Konduit.
This is our sweatiest comp so far.
This is our actual real comp so far.
It's like the only real one that makes sense.
Alright.
I swapped.
I'm back in.
Oh my god, this is it.
We're gonna...
My goal is...
As long as we're above Grieg's team, that's all I want.
That's all I want.
That's really all we want right now.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, warm-up's done, guys.
Yeah.
That's all we need.
If Peep can go from 19th to a win with 8, Yeah.
We should be able to do that.
Okay, but the thing is...
The thing that separates us from Peep is that all three of us are plat rank right now.
Wait...
Plat?
Diamond?
He's pred.
Yeah, so like, I don't know.
We're sort of like...
You know...
We got this.
Our team has to be like...
We're definitely the team of the people.
Yeah, we're the people's squad.
The amount of copium we're on right now is unreal.
We're the vibe team, guys.
We're the team that everyone likes, dude.
We are!
We can be multiple things!
Just not good?
Everything but good?
Can you really say that we're a good team with a straight face?
Yeah.
Only you can, Temple.
You're the only one.
He's the only one that has like...
is like, actually delusional.
He's the only one.
I like it, though.
We need that, though.
We need somebody that's not in reality.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, well...
Alright, this is our sweetest comp, bro.
We win this one.
There's no way.
We warmed up for like...
It doesn't matter.
It's the last one.
We got this.
Petition to play another Storm Point over Olympus.
Lowkey down for that.
To be honest.
Petition to reset score.
Oh my god!
So real?
No, we play Olympus?
We're definitely a team.
I know.
We're a team.
We're...
EA team.
We own Twitch.
All I'm saying is that...
Wig, I don't know why, but when you're headlining your Twitch rivals, it really...
Everything goes against you.
Not everything.
Not yet.
Not everything, though.
It's not about winning.
It's really about the friends when you win.
Why did you argue about me about that before when I said it wasn't about winning?
I'm trying to be positive now.
I've been pointing my motivations all the way through the floor.
So now it's not about winning.
No, of course.
Now it's not about winning.
Alright.
Exactly.
Well, we're up good and we haven't started yet.
Of course it's about winning.
When we start doing bad, then it's all about the friends.
I can't believe our first game was our peak.
That was actually the game where we had the most kills.
We have 11 points.
Pretty good.
Just need 7 or 8.
That's a lot of points.
8 points to get out of bottom 5.
We got 11 points just from 5 games.
I don't know.
8 points seems like a 5 game scenario.
You know what?
Wait, are we leaving...
letting Tempo roam free again?
Wait, where are we?
No, I can't.
There's no place to roam to.
We're in Turbine.
Yeah, but like...
If you survive as a solo...
If we're in Turbine, I can land Waterfall.
Yeah.
Yeah, we should let him roam free.
Wait, should we do it?
Why?
Let Tempo roam free again.
For the last game.
I'm so down.
Actually, Tempo, don't even come back to us.
What's the...
What's the butthole POI?
The butthole POI?
The Turbine?
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, fuck.
Rift?
The giant thick thingy.
What?
Bro, Tempo, you organized scrims.
Hammond.
Hammond?
It has a giant thingy that you can go in.
Okay, do we let Tempo roam free and not come back to us?
And then he can try and solo rat.
Yeah, I gotta go find a beacon.
Yeah.
I'm so down.
Okay, Tempo, don't come back to us.
Do you get a beacon in Turbine?
No.
I don't think so.
I'm gonna go steal Hammond.
Okay, this is it.
This is the game.
This is the game where we get 10 points.
This is the game where Tempo will rat until second place or some shit.
Yeah, that's double our points then.
Well, I should pick a small person.
We already established our characters.
What do you mean you should pick a small person?
Fuck me the fucking.
Let's do it.
No, we got this.
I'm Ash.
Yeah, you're Ash.
I am Conduit.
And Tempo is...
We just gotta trick someone into picking a character that's not there.
And then they get minus five.
Yeah, but they're gonna restart the game.
True.
Minus five.
They're just gonna restart the game unless they are stubborn enough.
Oh, there we go.
Give me Ash.
Oh, fuck.
I just broke my controller.
We're good.
Give me Ash.
I'm locked in.
I'm so locked in right now.
We're so locked in.
We're here.
We're ready.
Alright, my face is in my screen.
Oh, hell yeah, baby.
I wish I was your screen right now.
Let's go.
Bro, what?
Can you repeat that way?
Alright, here we go.
Do we have anything in Turbine?
We have nothing in Turbine.
Let's go.
We have a ring console for Tempo to scan.
Oh, we're so fucked.
We do?
We don't.
Yeah, yeah.
You're gonna go to Hammond.
I gotta wait for the team to land in Hammond.
And then I gotta steal their top loot.
Someone's actually taking Hammond?
God.
I'm gonna be worse than us, guys.
I don't know.
Is that person landing top Hammond?
Hey, why are you still with us, Tempo?
I forgot about the Shrath.
30 seconds.
Oh, wait.
Sorry.
I was watching the other team.
Too late now.
We're gone.
Tempo, why are you still here?
I came to steal your loot.
We literally talked about...
Don't go anywhere now.
We're on your feet.
Just stay with us.
We're talking about the Shrath.
Together.
How did you forget?
I was...
I don't know.
I love you both so much.
It's okay, buddy.
Don't worry.
I turned around in that one endgame.
We're the team of the people.
We're the team of the people, guys.
Remember.
This has to be fucking somewhere near us, dude.
Like, this needs to be near us.
There's just no way it's not.
It has to be somewhere fucking close.
It just has to be.
Where is a beacon that we can hit?
Power grid.
That's not good for us, actually.
That is not good for us.
We should not go there.
I think we take a gamble here.
Okay?
Yeah.
And I think we go towards docks.
Okay.
I believe in your gambles.
We have nothing left to lose.
We're literally...
We have to believe.
Oh, we do.
We have something to lose.
Greek, man.
We have one thing specifically that we can lose.
We have only one thing to lose.
There's a charge rifle right here, Tempo.
I got one.
Nice.
He has the one thing he needs.
Wasn't there a scalper somewhere?
I don't know where the scalper was.
I have no idea.
I haven't seen one.
They dropped it off my repeater.
Where the fuck did I put my repeater?
Oh my god.
I'm a mess right now.
Oh no.
You can't be a mess right now.
No.
I'm freaking out.
Don't freak out.
There's a repeater right here.
It's a hammer point.
Oh, here.
Okay.
I found it.
I'm so focused on the zone now that I just like...
Alright.
Let's go towards docks.
Anyone have an evac tower?
Any evac tower friends?
Nope.
I've only had a chance to look at one evac tower and we died really early on.
One moment.
And the drop killed us.
Alright.
Ready?
Yeah, I'm ready.
Let's move on through guys.
Let's do it.
Friendship.
Yay.
Hey, hey, hey.
Sound a little more exciting.
Yay.
Wall bounce.
I love it.
We're doing so well.
I don't know.
Okay.
Keep on moving guys.
I'm not gonna look up.
No.
We're good.
We're so good.
I'm not gonna look up.
I 100% just picked the wrong perk.
We're good.
I'm look... Oh.
Whoa.
I hear an evac tower in front of us.
That's good.
On me.
Literally right on us.
Yeah.
Like on me.
On me.
We're good.
Back up.
Keep moving.
Okay.
They conda queued.
Yeah.
I hear a fight to my left.
Just keep on coming guys.
Alright.
I'm going.
I'm walking forward.
They're taking the thing up now.
That's okay.
We're good.
We're just chilling here.
We're going to move up.
I just want these guys to leave.
We're good.
They're leaving.
I think.
No.
On me.
I'm not leaving.
No.
What are they doing?
These guys are stressing me the fuck out.
Okay.
Follow me.
You guys coming?
Yeah.
There's a Watson fence.
We gotta send it.
Believe in me.
I'm believing.
We're good.
Play slow, we're vibing.
We can play this pillar too if we need to.
We're okay.
Okay, I'm going to leave.
Go to the pillar, go to the pillar.
Yeah, I'm dead.
I'm good, I'm alive.
I'm alive, I think.
I'm dead.
I think, I think, I think I'm alive.
We're good, we're good, we're good.
Okay, I'm batting.
We're okay, we're okay.
Just play slow.
Play slow, we're fine.
Okay, there's a fence to our left here too.
We're vibing, just vibing guys.
We're so good.
Oh, I'm so good.
I feel so healthy.
We're so good.
We're so fine.
I feel very healthy right now.
I'm still vibing, it's not even funny guys.
Oh my god.
I'm dead.
We're alive, I'm good guys.
No, no, you're good, you're good, you're good.
Just fucking chill.
I'm looking to my right.
Live the fuck out, bro.
I'm alive, I'm dead.
We're okay, I think.
Oh, this is the... I don't know, man.
I don't feel very comfortable here.
I feel very exposed for some reason.
We're going to wait for my ulti and try to go up here.
Okay.
On that house.
But you guys stay here.
There's people literally right here.
Oh my god, what is this mirage doing?
How is he able to sit out here?
Man.
I'm just saying there's people right here above me.
Okay, that's fine.
We're good.
We're vibing.
We just lay low.
Chill out.
You know what I mean?
I'm stressed the fuck out.
I'm so stressed out.
But we're not 20th.
We're not 20th.
Yeah, but we need to...
Wow, bro.
How are these kids able to peek this?
I'm so lost how people are able to do this.
It's okay.
We're good.
Tembo, you're good where you're at.
You're fine.
Tembo, move up more here.
Here, right?
One place left.
Tembo, just don't.
We're good, guys.
How are these teams able to do this to us?
I'm getting harassed.
Tembo, please save us.
How are they able to get these angles?
I'm getting...
Why is no one here?
I'm getting harassed right now.
You're good.
I'm looking for you.
I'm pre-firing.
No one's there.
There's no safe .
Great fences, kid.
Good thinking, man.
Great fences, kiddo.
We're here.
They don't shoot us.
We're good.
Am I safe here or...
Yeah, you stay there, stay there.
Don't stay there.
Come on.
How are you getting shot?
Where are you getting shot from?
I don't know!
How is this possible?
No.
There's no .
There's no a us.
Dude, I'm so bad and...
A building would be nice.
A building would be fantastic right now.
We just take the car and eat a building?
No, you guys stay here.
I'm gonna try to figure something out.
Stay here.
This team above us must have so much space.
That's why they're doing this.
There's no way they're able to... there's no way.
I'm so scared, man.
We're actually lowkey not awful, if I'm being honest.
I was literally in the worst spot possible.
No, no.
This spot where I'm at is good.
Okay, I'm...
I'm okay now.
I'm not panicking anymore.
Guys, I've calmed down.
Did you?
Guys, you just threw up everywhere.
Guys, I'm chilling now.
Guys, I'm not anxious anymore.
I'm okay now.
I've calmed down.
I'm not stressed anymore, guys.
I think I feel like a better...
I feel like a much better person.
You know what?
Maybe this spot is doable.
You know?
If we lay low, like you guys just don't peek, no one's gonna think someone's playing here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
Not all of these Watson fences.
Who the fuck would play here, bro?
Honestly.
Yeah, who the fuck put all these Watson fences there?
There's nobody here.
I'm gonna be honest, guys.
If there's one thing I took today from all these games, in order for Challenge Circuit to work, I gotta step my eye jelly on it.
Holy fuck.
Oh my god.
I am rusty.
I think we all are.
We are all definitely rusty, I'll admit.
Wait, okay.
I just wanna know.
Is Greek's team dead?
I hope.
I haven't seen it.
I haven't seen 14 yet.
Oh, we haven't seen... No, fuck.
Okay, he's still alive.
It's so bad for us, guys.
That's so bad.
He's still alive.
We need to look at Team 14.
The only issue here that I'm...
The only issue we have, like genuinely, is if this team above us just... the zone like pulls up more and they're the only team inside docks, then they could... Oh, they're not.
They're getting shot at.
That's good.
Oh, nice.
Yeah.
That's good.
We're fine.
We're so healthy.
That's a great chat.
That's a great one.
Everybody knows we're here now, too, so that's okay.
No, it's fine.
That's great.
We're creating presence now, right?
Now we want presence.
Yeah, and now we want presence.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm learning.
I'm learning from your IGL.
Now we want people to know we're here.
Good.
You're doing so good.
I'm just gonna stay here, still.
I'm gonna... I'm gonna stay here.
There's people all over the room.
To be fair, though, we did get fucked over, like, pretty hard again.
Like, every time.
It's pretty horrible.
I think, like, I think...
I think everybody bullied us out of a good POI.
That's exactly what it is.
I think that's what happened.
Everybody just kicked us out.
They're like, okay, uh, next week, put Geyser.
They're like, uh, alright, yeah, they can have that.
They're like, alright, we'll take that for them.
They're like, oh, it's next week.
That's on there.
Like, I mean...
They don't even have a pro on their team.
Yeah, they don't even have a pro.
They literally have a platform and a diamond.
And another plat.
They literally have three plat players.
Okay, here's the moment of truth, guys.
Why is team 14 still...
Wait, but this is your tournament.
How did you let these people fucking... Oh, my god.
The zone pulls back.
Okay, this is gonna be the craziest thing I ever said.
We should get middle of fight night.
Like, inside fight night?
Yes.
How do we run past everybody?
I mean, I get this vehicle, we queue in there.
Or, I boost in there.
Okay, do we do it now?
Now?
Wait, wait, wait, come with me.
Doki, come over here.
Yeah.
Okay.
I have an ass port, but I think we should go for the trident because it's funnier.
Jesus Christ.
Go, go, go, go, go, go!
Boost, boost, boost, boost!
Get out, get out, get out, get out, get out!
No, I got in!
It's an all squad.
Why is there an all squad?
Get away, Doki, get away!
I'm in!
I'm getting punched already!
Why is there a hole in the back?
I'm taking the port!
Oh wait, that's not it.
Why is there a hole?
Is there a team inside?
There is already a full team inside!
Wig, I don't think we should have done that, Wig.
Where is Wig?
Where is he?
You live?
I'm alive, I'm alive, I'm alive.
All I'm saying is that Wig, I think you might have made the wrong decision.
Why is there a full team with an Arcstar there?
Why?
Someone please tell me why.
That is unbelievable.
Wait, you have no white bats?
No!
You have zero?
Land turbine!
I have nothing!
How do you have no zero?
You just gotta last until 14 minutes.
14 minutes!
Nothing matters anymore!
Nothing matters!
We can beat Deeds if you get uh...
12, 9, 7, 5.
If you get top 5, we beat Deeds.
The second, the person above us.
The person on the team above us and we beat...
Oh my god, the fucking riskiest reload After the audio play, there's no idea what I'm hearing.
You know, okay, maybe we should not listen to something that I was like, but it would be so funny.
Like, maybe that's just not...
Yeah, but like, who else smiled during that?
No one else?
I got stuck.
You got fucked over.
Wait, you got stuck or our car got stuck?
Because I got hit too.
Oh, maybe our car got hit and all of us...
No, why are you peeking?
Why are you looking?
I didn't know if they were still inside fighting or if I'm going in there and scrapping.
Look at your heels!
The fact that you have the confidence to even look at somebody.
At least some of us get top 10.
I'm fucking dead in this next zone, for sure.
You don't know that.
You can craft us in the north?
Craft you?
Okay, if he crafts us, where is he going to rez?
That's not delusional?
Come on.
Where is he going to rez, Tempo?
I should realistically die to Storm here so I don't give Deeds a kill.
Find a movie.
Do you know?
Wait, Tempo didn't even know CC was next week.
He thought it was the week after.
Oh, I thought so too.
Oh wait, what the fuck did you do?
I did not know to play next week.
I do not have enough time to prep for that.
We are playing next week, guys!
This is good.
People are dying.
There's no one middle.
Do I go middle?
Do it.
Inside?
Do it, do it, do it, do it, do it, do it, do it.
Do it and then there might be heals.
There might be heals.
There's heals.
There's my box on my left.
On the left.
That's me.
Right, right, right, right.
To your right.
I know.
I'm just nervous about these guys coming.
I'm nervous about them punching me in the face.
Just heal.
There's heals here.
Are you healing here?
No, I'm inside.
No, you're scared.
Yeah, yeah.
What the fuck do you mean?
Hey, chill.
Dottie, chill.
Just leave.
Just heal.
You have time.
I know, but they're going to push.
They're going to come in here.
They're not going to push.
And the other team is going to come in there.
Yeah, and then you watch these two come inside.
They scare each other out.
You're safe.
Yeah.
No one can come in because the moment they come in, someone else will come in.
It's a scare tactic.
They're just trying to scare you.
I'm fucking dead.
They're trying to scare you.
Oh my god.
What the fuck just happened to me?
Dottie!
Let's go!
You got lost.
You got lost so hard.
What the fuck was that?
What happened to me?
What was that?
Top 10 is crazy though.
Top 10 is so good.
Look at that.
No, it's okay.
We're above Greek.
Oh my god.
We actually got arced in the car.
We're above Greek.
That's all that matters.
You know what's crazy there?
If that team is just not there to stick with an R star, we actually probably could get like top five again.
Yeah, we could.
It's actually insane how bad our luck is.
It's unreal.
Yeah.
I'm just saying, wait, the next time you headline...
The next time you headline...
No, I call POIs.
I'm getting the POI out there.
Next time you have an idea.
Next time you think you have an idea, go against that idea as well.
Yo, what the...
Every idea I have, just make it the opposite.
That is insane.
I can't believe the headliner got bullied.
I can't believe none of their POIs.
That is insane.
I know.
To be fair, it's good that we got, you know, it's good that we finally got team practice, you know?
Oh, I understand.
Without a doubt.
Because if we didn't before Challenger Circuit, I think it would have been even worse.
Wait, what are we playing for Challenger Circuit?
I mean, listen, my brain is fried after these six games.
What is meta?
I just told us to get in three-man Trident and boost into five-man Trident.
I mean, am I really capable of IGL-ing anyone at this point?
Okay, but also remember where you took us before we were in the Trident.
That was even...
We were... I think we were safe down there.
Oh, I did not feel safe.
We were good.
I did not feel safe, 100%.
I mean, if we just had a fucking beacon.
I did not feel safe at all.
One time today.
One time we had a...
Do you understand that in order to get a beacon today, we just had to send Tempo over to Harvester.
That was the only time we had a beacon.
We just dropped a literal manager of an esports team solo at a POI to get a beacon.
We didn't get a single beacon.
That's actually crazy.
That is crazy.
All six games we had zero beacons.
We just played this game on a hard difficulty, literally veteran mode.
And it's fucking Mac again.
God damn it.
Fuck me.
That's actually insane.
That's insane.
We had one game of beacon, right?
What was it?
No, we didn't.
We had to walk over to the beacon.
Oh, no, no.
We had one in Jurassic.
Oh, we had Jurassic, yeah.
One out of five, baby.
One out of five.
Did we get fucked over in Jurassic still?
No, we didn't.
We didn't.
We did pretty well.
No, we just needed a cat wall and we would have made like top five.
Yeah.
That's my bad.
We had a...
You know what?
In the end, we had a good vibe.
Honestly, I actually had so much fun today.
Thank you guys.
I'm just glad we weren't last.
Wait, wait, guys.
We're not last, right?
We're better than Reptar.
Yeah, we're not last.
In the end, Reptar was rank one last season.
In the end?
Oh, my God.
And we were...
Our team did better than him.
You're so fucking right.
We technically beat the rank one Pred.
Are we rank 25?
Yeah.
We beat rank one Pred as a plaque team.
Just remember that.
No.
You're a platinum right now?
Yeah.
Hey, see?
A full platinum squad did better than Reptar.
Yeah.
Rank 0.5.
We'll take that shit.
Yeah.
That's our win.
That is our win today.
Oh, no.
That is the only thing I'm taking home with pride tonight.
Better than Reptar.
I know Greek needs a shot of alcohol so bad right now.
It's okay.
The fact that Greek lost to us.
Oh, and just also if he's getting 20th, then he didn't have a vibe squad like us.
Oh, boy.
Yeah.
He didn't get to have the fun part.
He didn't take a trident into a full team.
Wait, dude.
Come on, man.
We had no idea there was a team there.
It happened so fast.
I didn't even know what happened.
I didn't even...
Things were going to be bad because the moment...
The thing you said was...
I'm going to...
I'm going to do something that might not be a good idea, but it'll be really funny.
That's what you said.
It was funny.
I mean, I sent you alone to 1v3 fist fight inside of fight night.
That's pretty funny.
You were getting your ass beat inside of fight night 1v3.
At least we got the content out of the way.
We got real content.
We had real content.
No other team had as much fun as us.
Who is this winning right now?
I don't know.
This team winning might have a good time.
They just wasted all their grenades.
They're not even pushing over yet.
Why did they just waste all their grenades?
Oh, yeah.
This is the watch party.
This is your watch party time.
Exactly.
Look, Wig wanted to die early so he could watch party.
In-game watch party.
Yeah.
Here you go, chat.
Look at that.
And the win is going to go.
What's going on?
Nice.
Who won?
Wow.
Look at that endgame.
Oh, my God.
Who won?
That might be...
That might be Jen.
Jen, burn.
I think.
Oh, Jen.
Yeah.
Jen won.
Wait.
Do you actually memorize the skins?
Oh, my God.
Wasn't he, like, first place by, like, 30 points going in this game?
Yeah.
So did he just win by, like, 50 points?
I thought it was, like, 100 points.
Holy shit.
With girl, too?
Girls went crazy.
Man.
I wonder what that's like.
That was not us, guys.
I don't think we'll ever feel that.
No, you will.
Challenger circuit.
I don't think we'll ever know what that feels like.
Oh, my God.
We got fucking wrenched.
Guys, don't worry.
Look at where Team 14 is.
Good.
We're safe.
They didn't...
It would have been worrying if they got some kills.
Yeah, yeah.
Don't worry.
They had zero kills.
Wait.
How does Team 20 have three kills?
And they died in 20th?
I don't know.
They...
Wait.
What?
Yeah.
What the...
Or maybe they rez.
Maybe they rez.
They could have got picks and then the people rez.
Maybe.
We did it, guys.
We did it.
Guys.
Dude, what did we fucking get, man?
We had to get last.
No.
We're...
We're second last because...
We're second last.
Because Green's team never got a single point.
Is that your point?
Oh.
Everyone gets the same amount.
Yeah.
Everyone gets 400.
It's like 11th to 20th all get the same amount.
Okay.
Yeah.
So, we're fine.
It doesn't matter what place we're at.
Technically, we're 11.
Okay.
Makes sense.
Yeah.
Everybody's 11th place.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Everybody is 11th place.
So, technically...
Technically?
We're all 11th place.
Except for Green, who's 12th.
What?
Apparently, the team above us in Docs was Greek.
Wait.
Really?
They were probably...
Wait.
Really?
I'm asking.
They were probably so confused why we took the Trident and left.
They were probably so dumbfounded.
That is unbelievable.
There's no fucking way.
He's probably like, they're taking the fucking Trident?
That is so fucking funny.
Look at us.
Holy shit.
Look at us go.
Oh, my God.
I told you guys.
I bet you no one had as much fun as us, Chad.
Okay.
This was very good practice.
Yep.
For Challenger Circuit.
Agreed.
Yup.
Okay.
So, what did we learn today?
That we're gonna take it to Challenger Circuit?
I think...
Never get beacons, so don't bother with the controller character.
Okay.
No, that's not what we learned.
That's not what we learned.
That is not what we learned.
That is...
Thank God you understand what we learned today.
Okay.
Thank God we are talking about this now.
I just...
What do you mean?
That's exactly what we learned.
What we learned is that we need a POI with a scan.
Every game.
We need...
We need to figure out a POI.
And even we're gonna get contested.
Yeah.
We need...
We still need to figure out a POI and not get bullied out of our POI.
Unlike today.
I agree.
Yup.
And we need to figure out what to play.
Cuz apparently, we might be playing this game for seven hours on Saturday.
Yup.
Seven hours of that.
We need to do better than that.
Yeah.
And it's going to be next week for sure.
Right?
Is it actually next week or did I just gaslight you two thinking it's next week?
Yeah.
I know.
It's next week.
Okay.
It's actually next week.
Oh my God.
Bro.
Your fucking chat wig.
I can see why Tempo is the manager.
It's not in here.
Who said that?
Holy shit.
Where is it?
Wait a minute.
I have mud.
Oh, no.
Wait.
I know.
Oh, yeah.
100%.
Oh, my chat.
My chat's crazy right now.
Yeah.
I got shit on more today than I ever have in my life to be honest.
But my chat.
Are you going to be interviewed?
Cuz you're headlining this?
Hell no.
I was already interviewed.
Girl's going to get interviewed now.
What the fuck?
Are you going to be interviewed?
We should be having an interview for like the vibes.
I can't believe.
I can't believe we didn't get.
I can't believe you didn't bring us to the interview.
No.
Yeah.
They should get you on there.
No.
They should have got all of us.
What was your worst strategy today getting 19 place?
Well, NiceWeek told me three times to take a Trident when I shouldn't have.
And you know.
He denied me all correctly one time.
But you know.
We had a good time today.
Yeah.
He said like this was the last thing I heard was this might be a really bad idea, but it's going to be funny.
He said this is going to be funny.
And then none of us laughed afterwards.
Yeah.
And then we got Ark started.
I got confused.
I got so confused.
I didn't know what was going on.
All I know is I got stunned.
And then there was people.
Tempo had a bladder issue too.
So like honestly we should negate everything that happened.
Yeah.
We should just reset the scores.
Oh my God.
Reset and then multiply game one by six.
I don't think game one was the game that we did the best in.
It was like the best one we ever played.
This is the game four.
Yeah, we know.
We got like...
Green Pops out of six?
They won three games out of six.
Jen's team?
Yeah, that's fucking crazy.
Bro, that could've been me.
If I was... if Jen picked me.
You guys really got lost every game.
If Jen got you, he loses six out of six.
There's no way.
We should do a... we should have like a control group here.
Jen... every tournament, Jen will pick one of us.
And then see who plays us higher.
It's not gonna be me.
You're... you're playing higher than me sadly.
We gotta experiment here.
And see who's right.
That was so fucking fun, man.
Thank you guys so much.
I appreciate y'all for playing too.
Seriously guys.
That was really fun.
Let's play... maybe just fucking...
Maybe play some games or something like that if you guys want to.
Actually like ranked or anything.
We should really practice.
We should probably play a bit.
You guys wanna practice this week?
I'm down.
You got what?
Should it be next week?
Since CC's next week?
Oh yeah, that's what I meant.
Like Monday, my bad.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, isn't today Monday?
Today is...
Today's Friday.
Is what?
What?
Nothing, nothing.
Temple.
Yeah, it's Friday.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh.
Wait, did you not think it was Friday?
I forgot what day it was.
What?
Temple, how do you run shit so...
so efficiently but just don't even know the...
the week... the day of the week?
You're impressive, man.
I actually love you so much.
You're like the most functional, unfunctional person I've met in my life.
I'm not kidding.
Oh yeah, have you seen like...
Have you seen like all the...
like all of his... like his PC setup?
He has like five monitors or some shit.
Yeah, it's like he's like...
Yeah, and then Doki plastered all of her merch all over my screens.
Okay, not me.
It was like one of my...
one of my patents.
She's like, here you go, you should buy all of this Doki merch.
Buy Doki merch.
His walls are so barren.
Have you seen his walls?
Also, wait, you promised me you would buy like a Doki print and put it on your backdrop.
I promised you I'd buy it and then burn it.
You said you would put it behind you.
I'll get it behind you and I'll put it behind me and I'll burn it.
Alright, do it.
Do it.
Alright, deal.
Deal.
It's just your money.
Yeah, it's just my money.
It's just a picture of you.
It's literally your money.
Oh yeah, speaking of...
subs.
Oh my god, how many do you deserve, Tempo?
What is the sub count actually?
Tempo got like...
Wait, how many kills did we get?
Tempo got four kills.
Oh my god, did you?
That's 40 subs.
Four kills?
Five subs per kill, no?
Yeah, so 20 subs.
20 subs.
To Tempo, right?
Yeah, to Tempo.
And then 20...
No, you said 20 subs to me and Tempo.
Yeah, I'll do it.
Wait, I can't gift Tempo subs.
Wait, what?
Are you not even an affiliate, Tempo?
No, I can't.
I can't.
Alright, 20 gifted to Tempo.
Wait, gift one sub when I run.
20 subs is $100.
We got five kills?
Yeah, you got five?
You got five?
We have five kills.
I don't know whose kills these are.
I have an interview with the winners.
I have no idea what's going on.
Wait, can we join?
I'll ask them.
I'll ask them too.
Oh no.
We'll just be like, hey, we're gonna be here to help interview.
I'll see, I'll see.
We just fucking crashed the interview.
By the way, Tempo, I made up that number.
I don't even know how many kills you got.
Yeah, I don't know how many kills we got.
I see total kills as five, so...
So four, we'll stay with five.
We'll stay with five.
It says total kills.
He doesn't know.
He's not gonna fact check.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
So five kills, right?
That's 25 subs for you!
It's payday!
Okay, we're back.
What is Wig gonna do?
Review the VOD?
Exactly.
She's not gonna review the VOD.
Guys, I don't think Wig's gonna... I don't think he's coming back, guys.
I think he's gonna come back, but the interview's gonna be over.
He didn't bring us back to the room.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe he didn't bring us into the interview room.
He left us!
That's so fucked up!
He's about to interview now.
That's fucked up!
He didn't even tell us!
He didn't drag us in!
Oh my god!
He actually just went peace!
And left us!
I'm gonna message him.
Shake my head.
Actually left us.
Can't believe it.
He left for milk.
He actually left us.
We're like the only one...
Oh wait, no, actually I was gonna say...
I thought we were like the only one in VC, but we can only see our own VCs.
Yeah, and then the one above us.
We can click into the...
Oh no, nevermind.
We can't click.
Guys, we doubled...
We doubled Greek's score.
Did we double Greek's score?
Guys, we doubled Greek's score!
We doubled his score.
Guys, we did it!
We're better than the rank one Pred last season.
Just remember that!
Any team...
We're better than the team that was...
that had a rank one Pred.
That's all it takes.
Oh my god.
Look, last look...
It's cause the current season doesn't have rank one yet.
We don't know who's the current rank one Pred yet this season.
We don't know.
We don't know, so it doesn't matter, chat.
Yeah, cause it hasn't ended yet.
We're the...
God's strongest...
Did it end yet?
No, it didn't.
What do you mean?
The season's still ongoing.
Is rank season still ongoing?
Oh, right.
It ends next week.
Yeah.
It's still ongoing.
Okay, so we're good.
We're good.
We're good to go.
You know, I think we did pretty well.
I think we did pretty well as a team.
I had...
I had zero expectations.
I still have zero expectations, but...
I thought we were gonna get in the middle.
I know.
It wasn't gonna happen.
I mean...
With our POIs, there was no way.
Like, literally, we had zero good POIs.
Wig literally got kicked out of all the good POIs.
The last Twitch Rivals we did, Wig actually had decent places to land.
Yeah.
We actually had loot.
Let's see if they...
That's true.
Let's...
Yeah.
We were...
We were what?
Grow towers?
We had loot.
Yeah.
We had actual loot and we weren't getting contested.
This time, we...
We got contested every time.
Or not every time.
We...
We got kicked out of our areas.
What is POI?
It's like...
I forgot what...
What's the abbreviation for POI?
It's like the landmarks.
So where you're landing.
I don't know what the abbreviation is.
I forgot.
POI?
Point of interest.
Oh, POI.
POI.
Point of interest.
So it's basically where teams get to pick where you want to land.
The landmarks and stuff.
And then we tried to pick good spots.
But then every other team kicked us out.
Every team kicked us out of the spots.
So all...
So we got the spots that were considered like absolutely trash loot with zero...
With zero hope.
He's weak.
He's a little bitch.
Oh my god.
This...
I don't even know how long this interview is gonna be.
How long is this interview?
It just started.
Wait, they just started the interview?
Yeah.
Oh no.
They a...
Oh my god.
They just started the interview.
I can't believe it.
How long are we gonna be waiting here?
Yeah, the interview just started now.
Okay, if this interview is gonna take really, really, really long.
I might peace out soon.
I think it takes like 15...
Fifteen minutes?
Four and a...
All right GGs Tempo.
Tell Wig that I couldn't wait 15 minutes.
I couldn't wait...
GGs.....
I have zero patience.
All right, GGs Tempo.
You have to do your schedule, right?
Yeah, I have to do my schedule.
When did you want to play?
What do you mean?
I do it on Saturday.
When did you want to play ranked?
I think most likely I won't be streaming it because I also have another Apex tournament too, other than CC.
So I don't want to put too many Apex on.
I'll most likely just play off- like you guys can stream, but I'll play off stream.
Okay.
Wait, you mean the one tomorrow, right?
What?
No, not that, next week.
I mean next week I have another Apex tournament other than the CC one.
Oh, really?
Okay, okay.
Yeah, it's not been announced yet so I can't really say much about it.
Oh, okay, gotcha.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Alright, GG's.
Bye, I'll see you next- or no wait, I'll see you tomorrow.
Yeah, yeah, I'll see you tomorrow at finals.
Bye-bye.
Alright, alright, guys.
Uh, I'm gonna call it here because like I actually- I cannot wait 15 minutes.
I don't want to watch- I don't want to watch an interview for 15 minutes, guys.
I don't want to watch it, but I had a great time.
I had a great time.
I always love playing with Wig and Tempo.
Um, we're just like fucking around.
I had very low expectations and it's not last.
I'm fine with that.
I'm fine.
We beat the rank one Fred team.
That's fine with me.
I'm happy with that.
The fact that we weren't last is good enough for me.
It's good enough for me.
Um, but it was honestly- it was really fun.
Um, yeah, it exceeded my very, very low expectations.
Um, and I hope you guys had a fun time watching.
Um, uh, if you're new here, I usually stream on the YouTubes.
So please check me out over there.
Uh, exclamation point socials to see all the social- social media stuff I have.
Um, for Twitch streams, um, I usually tweet- tweet it out whenever I'm streaming on Twitch.
And so please follow me on Twitter to know for my Twitch updates.
Uh, what else?
What else?
Oh, yes.
Uh, if you want to support me via other means, please check out my merch.
Also, we're Twitch Partner!
This is my first Twitch Partner stream!
Thank you everybody for coming!
I hope you guys enjoyed the first Twitch- I've never been Twitch Partner before.
This is the first time I've ever been Twitch Partner!
Thank you everyone!
I hope you guys had a- uh, you guys had a fun time coming up to my very first Twitch Partner stream.
Uh, thank you for all the gifted subs, all the biddies, um, all the donations, all the follows.
I really, really, really do appreciate it, guys.
Um, as always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stood up for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time, everybody!
Bye, guys!
Bye!